programming throwdown episode 179 project planning take it away jason hey everybody um it is so fun to to actually uh do these duo shows i have to say i think the interviews were super lucky that we could get such a like multi-disciplinary set of talented people to do interviews and i appreciate everybody you know reaching out we get many many requests to interview yeah we do we get a lot yeah we get we get i get a ton in my personal email too that you don't even see oh you get a lot in your personal email nope yeah see mine's too available um so we really appreciate it i mean we're honored that so many people want to be on the show but but uh it's just really fun just the two of us talking about tech stuff so we're gonna keep it like this for a little while um and i will kick us off
Programming Throwdown 第 179 期，项目规划。Jason，交给你了。嘿，大家好。说实话，能做这种双人节目真的很有趣。我觉得我们请到的采访嘉宾非常幸运，能有这么多跨学科的优秀人才参与，我很感谢每一位联系我们的人，我们收到了非常多的采访请求。是的，确实很多。我的个人邮箱里也收到了海量请求，你甚至都没看到过。哦，你的个人邮箱也收到这么多？没，是的，你看，我的邮箱太公开了。所以我们真的很感激，也很荣幸有这么多人想上节目，但只有我们俩聊聊技术话题真的很有趣，所以我们会保持这种形式一段时间。那么，我先来开个头。
with a store that we opened so or i say by we now i'm talking about my wife and i and really by we i mean my wife open i i did a lot of the manual labor but um um but we opened a, it's called Bricks and Minifigs. It's a franchise and it's basically an event space and a retail space. So on the retail side, they sell Lego, they sell like bricks and minifigs as suggested, like sets and all that they also have like a thing where you can build your own minifigure and then it's also kind of like a clearinghouse for lego i didn't realize this was a thing but but people will want to sell their lego right which makes sense after they built it and played with it the thing that surprised me was there's a huge audience of people who want to buy already built lego whoa yeah that i did not know that not expecting and and you know now the store is up you uh see it every day like i'll be in the store building some furniture or something and someone will uh say like oh that would look really good on our coffee table and they just buy it as if they're at like an art gallery or something um and and a lot of these people
从我们开的一家店说起。或者说“我们”，现在我指的是我和我妻子，其实说“我们”主要是我妻子开的，我做了很多体力活。我们开了一家店，叫 Bricks and Minifigs。这是一家特许经营店，基本上是一个活动空间和零售空间。在零售方面，他们卖乐高，正如名字所暗示的，卖积木和人仔，还有套装之类的。他们还有一种可以让你自己拼装人仔的服务，而且它也算是一个乐高交易中心。我以前没意识到还有这种生意，但人们确实想卖掉他们的乐高，这很合理，毕竟拼完玩过之后嘛。让我惊讶的是，有一大群人想买已经拼好的乐高。哇，真的吗？是的，我之前不知道，也没想到。现在店开起来了，你每天都能看到，比如我会在店里组装家具什么的，有人会说：“哦，那个放在我们的咖啡桌上看起来一定很棒。”然后他们就直接买走了，就像在艺术画廊一样。而且这些人中有很多……
actually don't want to build it they actually just just want to have it. So I'm really surprised at that. Now, the other part of the business, which is honestly the part that really I like the most is the event space. So we do birthday parties, all different other corporate events and stuff, and people build Lego. We have actually this cool racetrack where there's like a metal car, like a chassis, a metal chassis of a car that has the Lego studs on it. And so you build a car and try and race it down the track, uh,
其实并不想自己拼，他们只是想拥有它。所以我对此感到非常惊讶。现在，业务的另一部分，老实说也是我最喜欢的部分，就是活动空间。我们举办生日派对、各种企业活动之类的，人们在那里拼乐高。我们其实有一个很酷的赛道，上面有一个金属车，就像一个底盘，上面有乐高凸点。所以你可以拼一辆车，然后试着在赛道上比赛。
kind of Pinewood Derby style. Nice. Um, and, uh, I guess, you know, I mean,
有点像松木赛车（Pinewood Derby）那种风格。不错。嗯，我想，你知道，我的意思是……
beyond just, uh, shilling the store for, for the, for the 1% of listeners who happen to be in texas um you know i want to talk a little bit about career breaks so you know i um i basically took a career break and um i actually you know did a lot of side projects and things like that but i also helped uh my wife kind of get the store off the ground and um it was
除了为那 1% 恰好在德克萨斯州的听众推销这家店之外，我想聊聊职业空窗期。你知道，我基本上休了一个职业空窗期，我确实做了很多副业之类的事情，但也帮我妻子把店开起来了，这……
awesome i mean i know that this is like a uh um thing that might not be accessible to everybody but you know if you could take you know a short break and especially if you've been in the industry you know 10 15 20 years um you know it's uh it's really nice to just you know instead of i was always a type of person where if i decided i wanted to change jobs you know i would still keep like working you know really hard at my current job until i found the next thing and then i would leave like a one day gap or something between the first job and the second job um and you know this time like having a longer gap is uh really really nice especially if you've been in the industry for a long time i highly recommend it people talk about uh i guess maybe it used to be more common maybe it was never more
太棒了。我知道这可能不是每个人都能做到的，但如果你能休个短假，特别是如果你已经在行业里工作了 10、15、20 年，真的很好。我以前总是那种人，如果我决定换工作，我会在找到下一份工作之前一直努力工作，然后两份工作之间只留一天左右的空档。但这次，有更长的空档期真的非常好，特别是如果你在行业里待了很久，我强烈推荐。人们谈论……我想也许过去这更常见，也许从来都不常见，我不太清楚，但关于休假（sabbatical）……
common i don't really know but sabbaticals um yeah that's i don't really know like what what goes into a sabbatical but But first of all, congratulations. Tough thing to do. So good luck. Thanks. I won't quote all the statistics about new businesses to you, but I'm just teasing. It helps that there's not like a default. Like, what is it?
是的，我不太清楚休假具体是怎么回事。但首先，恭喜你。这很难做到。祝你好运。谢谢。我就不跟你列举那些关于新创企业的统计数据了，我只是开个玩笑。如果不是默认的那种情况会有帮助。比如，那是怎么说的？
Who's the person who... Paul Graham. He says, says you know startups are default dead until they're profitable but in our case like we don't really have to be profitable um it's just really a fun thing for the community so i think that helps our survival rate there you go uh non unintentional non-profit um no i'm sorry i just teased no no best wishes best wishes um but yeah i mean i think like taking a career break change of things is is actually like a good advice and there's a lot of new ones not to derail like into this for for very long but just if you're planning to leave
那个人是谁……Paul Graham。他说，初创公司在盈利之前默认是“死亡”的，但在我们这种情况下，我们并不一定要盈利，这只是为了社区做的一件有趣的事，所以我认为这有助于我们的存活率。原来如此，无意中的非营利组织。不，抱歉，我只是开个玩笑。不，最好的祝福，最好的祝福。但确实，我认为休个职业空窗期、换换环境是一个很好的建议，而且有很多细微差别。为了不偏离主题太久，如果你打算离开……
a position just look at like what the rules are around most places your insurance coverage is a concern so people don't want gaps because of insurance but uh in a lot of places once the first of the month hits your insurance is basically paid for the month by your company and your premium so if you stop on the second of the month or whatever you're actually covered for the rest of the month and so you could take you know a four-week break basically and you know have insurance coverage without any any gap now again you should please like read that that's not something you really ask your manager right because then you're kind of admitting you're yeah uh leaving but for something that if it's helpful to plan for and plan around it can ease some of the stuff that that make it a little more accessible i would say to take a little bit of a gap. And then you can also,
一个职位，只要看看大多数地方的规定。保险覆盖范围是一个顾虑，所以人们因为保险不想有空窗期。但在很多地方，一旦到了月初，你的保险基本上就已经由公司和你的保费支付了当月的费用。所以如果你在月初的第二天左右离职，你实际上在那个月的剩余时间里是有保险的。所以你基本上可以休四周的假，而且没有任何保险空窗期。当然，请务必阅读相关条款，这不应该去问你的经理，因为那样你就等于承认你要离职了。但如果能提前规划，这可以减轻一些压力，让休假变得更容易实现。然后你还可以……
in many positions in tech, you can negotiate a signing bonus to help cover that. And that's not necessarily always obvious or offered, but you can always ask for, hey, I'm going to take this, I'm convincing my spouse or whatever, I need a little bit of help to take a vacation in between. Say whatever excuse helps it in your head if negotiating is hard for you to try to ask for a little bit more of a signing bonus and your negotiating power starting the new job. But I do agree taking time to do something off. People talk about online. I've never done it. I kind of envy it, but it's like an early retirement, like a a mini retirement we kind of wait till the very end of our careers and then we retire and never work again that's at least the their sort of stereotypical thing there's no reason
在科技行业的许多职位中，你可以协商签约奖金来帮助支付这段时间的费用。这不一定总是显而易见的或主动提供的，但你总是可以要求：“嘿，我要休这个假，我在说服我的配偶，我需要一点帮助来度过这段空档期。”如果协商对你来说很难，就找任何能让你心里好受的借口，试着要求多一点签约奖金，并在开始新工作时增加你的谈判筹码。但我确实同意花时间做点别的事情。人们在网上谈论这个，我从来没做过，我有点羡慕，但这就像提前退休，像一个“迷你退休”。我们通常等到职业生涯的最后才退休，然后就再也不工作了，这至少是那种刻板印象。没有理由……
why you couldn't save money take a year then return to work and for many people um returning isn't that hard after a year you It is very situational and person dependent. And compounding of money does make there a slight problem to the hand wavy. It doesn't make a difference. But if it allows you to come back to work with new freshness, new eyes and new vigor and energy, I would argue there's compounding returns from that as well in your job performance and how people are happy so yeah i think taking a break is is great advice yeah totally i would say a couple of things based on what you said one is um there's this thing called cobra which is probably just an american thing but there's probably equivalents in other parts of the world where you get your employer's insurance for an extra year after you've left. Now you have to
你为什么不能存点钱，休一年假，然后再回去工作？对很多人来说，一年后回去并不难。这非常取决于具体情况和个人。金钱的复利确实会带来一点问题，但这并不重要。但如果它能让你以新的活力、新的视角和新的精力回到工作中，我认为这在你的工作表现和人们的幸福感方面也有复利回报。所以是的，我认为休假是一个很好的建议。是的，完全同意。基于你说的，我想补充几点。一是有一种叫 COBRA 的东西，这可能只是美国的东西，但世界其他地方可能有类似的，就是你离职后可以继续使用雇主的保险一年。现在你必须……
pay for it, but at least you don't have to change all your doctors and all of that stuff. So that is an option. It's also kind of interesting. You have the option of retroactively getting COBRA. So for example, you could say like oh you know i'm just going to go without insurance for six months and then oh you break your arm you can actually sign up for cobra like after they've fixed up your arm and everything and they'll retroactively like recalculate all of your medical expenses which is pretty wild um i mean it's actually kind of remarkable just from a tech standpoint that they can do that um and then the other thing i was going to say um oh yeah you know i think it's important to have some kind of a goal uh you know i actually told people when i was leaving uh my last job
自己付钱，但至少你不必更换所有的医生之类的。所以这是一个选择。还有一个很有趣的地方，你可以选择追溯性地获得 COBRA。例如，你可以说：“哦，我知道了，我打算六个月不买保险。”然后，哦，你摔断了胳膊，你实际上可以在他们治好你的胳膊之后再申请 COBRA，他们会追溯性地重新计算你所有的医疗费用，这太疯狂了。我的意思是，从技术角度来看，他们能做到这一点真的很了不起。然后我想说的另一件事是……哦，是的，我认为设定一个目标很重要。你知道，我离开上一份工作时确实告诉了人们……
they said oh what are you doing next and i just i had it ready to go i was like here's what i'm doing i'm gonna help my wife build a retail store and uh and so it's like i think having a plan um you know helped a lot i i feel like uh um if you if you just uh you know veg out for a while that's fine that's a different kind of career break than saying i'm going to like hike a mountain or travel the world or whatever and if you're going to have some kind of focus then then you should plan it all beforehand because you don't want to waste your time not getting paid planning you know that's that's time where that you could you could be doing that on the nights and weekends while you work your job you know you're not working the nights and weekends you know do you i i almost never work weekends unless things are really wrong i will work a lot
他们问：“你接下来要做什么？”我早就准备好了，我说：“这就是我要做的，我要帮我妻子开一家零售店。”所以我觉得有一个计划帮助很大。我觉得如果你只是在那儿“躺平”一段时间，那没问题，但这和你打算去爬山、环游世界之类的职业空窗期是两码事。如果你打算有某种重点，那么你应该提前计划好，因为你不想浪费时间在没有报酬的规划上。你知道，那是你可以在工作之余的晚上和周末做的事情。你不在晚上和周末工作吗？我几乎从不加班，除非情况真的很糟糕。我会……
during the week but i will not work a weekend unless i absolutely have to yeah unless it's just like a really quick statement or whatever by default if someone is saying i anticipating that i need to do it then they've they've needed incorrectly i guess is yeah i try and i try to do that for you know the people that i help on the teams and stuff as well it's like we shouldn't plan that the work needs you know more than the normal working hours yeah i don't know if you feel this way but i get more and more energy as i work so like by 5 p.m like i'm really really excited about work and And then by, let's say, 8 a.m. the next day, it's like I have to start the train again. And I've been this way my whole life. It's not an age thing. Even when I was 20 years old working, I still had this mentality.
在工作日期间工作很多，但我绝对不会在周末工作，除非我必须这样做。是的，除非这只是一个非常简短的声明之类的。默认情况下，如果有人说我预料到我需要这样做，那他们就预料错了。是的，我尽量为我帮助的团队成员也这样做。我们不应该计划让工作需要超过正常工作时间。我不知道你是否有这种感觉，但我工作得越久精力越充沛。所以到下午 5 点时，我对工作感到非常兴奋。然后到第二天早上 8 点，就像我必须重新启动火车一样。我这辈子一直都是这样，这不是年龄问题。即使我 20 岁工作时，我也有这种心态。
And so it's like, I would rather work a ton of hours on Friday than come in on Saturday and work for four hours and get pretty much nothing done. So, you know, it's like, it's like, you know, that, that, uh, um, I feel like that works a lot better. No, I don't share that trait. Um, yeah, but I, but I know, I think everyone's different and I think, yeah, I, we can get into that when we talk about planning for projects, but I think different people have different ways of into that when we talk about planning for projects. That's true. People have different ways of reacting to things. All right. Well, I think it's time for the news.
所以，我宁愿在周五多工作几个小时，也不愿在周六来工作四个小时却几乎什么都没做成。所以，我觉得那样效果好得多。不，我没有这个特点。嗯，但我知道，我认为每个人都不同，我想，是的，当我们谈论项目规划时我们可以深入探讨，但不同的人有不同的反应方式。确实如此。人们对事物的反应方式不同。好吧，我想是时候播报新闻了。
Oops, sorry. All right. What is your news, Patrick? My first topic was an interesting, I don't even know, these show up on social media. Sometimes you see them on X or on Reddit or wherever, and someone just posts this and a conversation spins up and everyone's talking about it. And anyways, this one was, someone had posted a GitHub gist
哎呀，抱歉。好吧，你的新闻是什么，Patrick？我的第一个话题很有趣，我甚至不知道，这些出现在社交媒体上。有时你在 X 或 Reddit 或其他地方看到它们，有人发了帖子，然后对话就开始了，每个人都在谈论它。总之，这次是有人发了一个 GitHub Gist……
where they put some numbers down and I can't speak to the veracity, the sort of correctness of these numbers, but they were saying that they were a big contributor on Stack Overflow and that they were posting these numbers to say that you know stack overflow number of new questions has been going down it of course uh you know sparked an interesting
他们在上面列了一些数字，我无法保证这些数字的准确性，但他们说他们是 Stack Overflow 的大贡献者，他们发布这些数字是为了说明 Stack Overflow 的新问题数量一直在下降。这当然引发了一场有趣的……
online discussion around it and so i just bring it up here because i think it is interesting on the one hand i don't know have you ever jason posted a question on Stack Overflow? Oh man, that is itself a great question. I've literally never done that. I've answered questions, but I'm definitely not like a top answer or anything. I've literally never posted a question. I haven't either, but I have read enough stories. Like one of these things, I guess,
在线讨论。我在这里提出来是因为我觉得这很有趣。一方面，我不知道，Jason，你在 Stack Overflow 上提过问题吗？天哪，这本身就是一个好问题。我真的从来没做过。我回答过问题，但我绝对不是什么顶级回答者。我真的从来没发过问题。我也没发过，但我读过足够多的故事。就像这些事情之一，我想……
like in my head, I've built it up to be a thing where I don't think there's a lot of low effort questions. They get closed. And I think over time, Stack Overflow has gone through curation to try to, you know, get good quality questions asked. And so I think part of it, and you hear the same thing about Wikipedia. I've never edited a Wikipedia article, largely for what I would say is kind of the same reason you read stories about people who talk about the, you know, over process and the context
在我的脑海里，我把它想象成一个我不认为有很多低质量问题的地方。它们会被关闭。我认为随着时间的推移，Stack Overflow 经过了筛选，试图提出高质量的问题。所以我认为部分原因是这样，你在维基百科上也听过同样的话。我从来没有编辑过维基百科条目，很大程度上是因为和你说的原因一样，你读过关于人们谈论过度流程和背景的故事……
around what's expected of you if you're going to and i just yeah uh quick quick side note i tried to create a wikipedia page for the show and uh it got rejected this was like 12 years ago or something because we weren't noteworthy or what was yeah they didn't at the time we didn't have enough news stories about us at the time we had zero i probably could make one now but to your point it's like once you get rejected like i put in a lot of time into that yeah and then it's just gone they i think uh i think they literally delete it to where like you just can't even get it anymore and so it's like who wants to work on wikipedia after that uh yeah a bit of an
关于如果你要参与，对你有什么期望。我只是……快速插一句，我试过为这个节目创建一个维基百科页面，结果被拒绝了。那是 12 年前的事了，因为我们不够出名，或者是什么……是的，当时我们关于我们的新闻报道不够多，当时我们是零。我现在可能可以做一个了，但回到你的观点，一旦你被拒绝，我投入了很多时间，然后它就消失了。我想他们甚至会直接删除它，让你根本找不到它。所以谁还想在维基百科上工作呢？是的，有点题外话……
aside and i'm thankful that there are people that do and they become committed to the idea of i'm going to do this it's like an iterative thing right you get shut down they submit again they try something different they're persistent and once you get over that hurdle i do believe like it can be very valuable for you to continue sort of writing articles submitting things but if you're just seeing it as like a very transactional i want to do this one time i agree i think the bar in my head at least gets to where i i don't attempt it um but i will but but that's not where the conversation went although i i think we should be aware of that the conversation immediately jumped on not not
我很感谢那些这样做的人，他们致力于“我要做这件事”的想法。这就像一个迭代的过程，对吧？你被拒绝了，他们再次提交，尝试不同的东西，他们很坚持。一旦你跨过了那个障碍，我相信这对你继续撰写文章、提交内容非常有价值。但如果你只是把它看作是一次性的交易，我同意，至少在我心里，门槛高到我不会去尝试。但这不是对话的方向，尽管我认为我们应该意识到这一点。对话立即跳到了……
surprisingly to everyone's just asking their questions to ai instead um and so there were some points and counterpoints which is a very interesting discussion about stack overflow uh profit has actually stayed up in part because um they've been able to license all of these questions and answers to ai training um and so in some ways the sort of questions have gone on to those platforms because more than just a search, they've sort of been able to aggregate and combine all of the information there into the LLMs that you can then interact with and sort of be more responsive and ask your questions. And then not to get sort of conspiracy,
不出所料，每个人都只是在问 AI 问题。所以有一些观点和反观点，关于 Stack Overflow 的讨论非常有趣。利润实际上保持了增长，部分原因是他们能够将所有这些问答授权给 AI 训练。所以在某种程度上，这些问题已经转移到了那些平台上，因为它们不仅仅是搜索，它们已经能够将那里的所有信息聚合并组合到 LLM 中，你可以与之交互并更及时地得到回答。然后，不是要搞什么阴谋论……
but you get kind of the dead internet theory. Then the problem is, okay, but all of the questions about new languages and this, how do we get that information out on to, to Stack Overflow? And so just a very interesting discussion. I don't have a sort of strong held opinion or belief here, but just as the internet sort of rolls forward, we, I, I've benefited many times from going on Stack Overflow and sort of seeing questions and response style. it fits very naturally with the kind of work that I do. And so it's very useful.
但你得到了所谓的“死互联网理论”。那么问题是，好吧，但是关于新语言的所有问题，我们如何把这些信息放到 Stack Overflow 上？所以这是一个非常有趣的讨论。我在这里没有强烈的观点或信念，但随着互联网的发展，我多次从 Stack Overflow 上看到问题和回答中受益。它非常自然地契合我所做的工作类型。所以它非常有用。
I personally haven't shifted a ton of that over to sort of artificial intelligence, but maybe I will in the future. But then what about the questions about the next libraries and all of that that never get posted on Stack Overflow? You know, yeah, over time, does it naturally sort of fade into the sunset and we
我个人并没有把大量内容转移到人工智能上，但也许将来会。但那些关于新库的问题呢？那些永远不会发布在 Stack Overflow 上的问题呢？你知道，随着时间的推移，它会自然地消失，我们……
you know just go other places i i mean probably it's a natural course but an interesting discussion nonetheless yeah i mean i think to your dead internet theory point it's like when when you when you ask an ai a question it might be a question that the ai's never thought of before seen before but it can piece together an answer from you know all the other questions it's seen the problem is really that that answer is not in stack overflow and so like you're not growing the collective consciousness if the ai just like tells you the answer and then it's deleted so maybe the ai's need a blog where like they when they have these novel thoughts they're sort of aggregated collected and then published and then the ais can help the other
只是去其他地方吗？我想这可能是自然的过程，但无论如何这是一个有趣的讨论。我的意思是，对于你的“死互联网理论”观点，当你问 AI 一个问题时，它可能是一个 AI 从未想过或见过的问题，但它可以从它见过的所有其他问题中拼凑出一个答案。问题在于，那个答案不在 Stack Overflow 上，所以如果你只是让 AI 告诉你答案，然后它就被删除了，你就没有在增长集体意识。所以也许 AI 需要一个博客，当它们有这些新颖的想法时，它们会被聚合、收集并发布，然后 AI 可以帮助其他……
ais grow and it can be no that's not gonna happen yeah no you know what's what's funny is actually when you were saying that i was like yes yes that's right i think that actually is where it'll go i think i think the ai will uh you could do some kind of like novelty detection it's like oh this is a novel question then we'll post the answer the question and the answer maybe on stack overflow so stack overflow have a bunch of questions and answers from ai and then people can go and correct it and all that yeah it'll be i use ai a ton actually the other day um i wanted to do this is a little weird well hard to explain but i wanted to do like 2000 gaussian mixture models in parallel and so i wanted to vectorize it so that i would without like a for loop because one thing about machine learning stuff or just you know in general these kind of
AI 成长，这不会发生的。是的，你知道什么很有趣？其实当你这么说的时候，我在想：是的，是的，没错。我认为这确实是它会发展的方向。我认为 AI 会……你可以做某种新颖性检测，比如“哦，这是一个新颖的问题”，然后我们会把问题和答案发布在 Stack Overflow 上。所以 Stack Overflow 会有一堆来自 AI 的问答，然后人们可以去纠正它之类的。是的，我会用 AI，其实前几天……我想做这个，有点奇怪，很难解释，但我想要并行做 2000 个高斯混合模型，所以我想要向量化它，这样我就不用 for 循环了。因为机器学习或者一般情况下，这些东西……for 循环会扼杀你的性能，对吧？所以如果你做 for x 从 0 到 1000，a += x 或者 a += i，对吧？你这样做是为了对数组求和，或者你只是在整个数组上使用某种 sum 运算符。后者会快几百倍，对吧？所以我需要一种完全向量化的方式来做一堆高斯混合模型。我问了 AI，我很确定没人问过 AI 做这个，它给出了一个答案，而且完全正确。所以这就是那种应该以某种方式进入 Stack Overflow 的东西。是的，我有相反的经历。我问了一个问题，它给我的答案显然是错的，写了一些示例代码，写了所有这些东西，然后……
things like for loops kill your performance right so so if you do like 4x from zero to a thousand you know a plus equals x or a plus equals i, right? So you do that to sum an array, or you just use like some sum operator on the whole array. The second one's going to be like hundreds of times faster, right? And so I needed a totally vectorized way to do a bunch of Gaussian mixture models. And I asked AI, and I'm fairly confident nobody's asked ai to do this and it produced an answer and it was actually totally correct and so that's the kind of thing that like probably should have somehow made its way into stack overflow yeah i had an opposite experience i asked a question that it gave me an answer which was obviously wrong wrote some sample code wrote all this stuff and
然后我只是说，我甚至告诉它“我不知道，不管怎样，那是不对的”。它说：“你是对的，我确实弄错了。”然后它继续写了别的东西，所以它实际上仍然是不正确的，但至少更接近了，没那么明显地错误。我发现这就像……偏离了你的话题，对我来说这是一种非常奇怪的心理状态，就像通过简单地告诉它它是错的，就像如果你多思考一会儿，你会给我第二个回答吗？你不能自己告诉自己吗？“你确定吗？”这非常奇怪。所以它和去 Google 搜索博客文章或 Stack Overflow 完全不同。所以，是的，我仍然没有……
then i was just like and i'd even just told i was just i don't know whatever like that's not right and it's like you're correct i did get it wrong actually and then it proceeded to write something else so it's actually still incorrect but at least like closer and less obviously wrong and i found this like you know sort of you know diverging off your thing you know i i it was a very weird mental thing for me to be like by simply telling it it was wrong it's like if you had thought longer would you have given me the second response like couldn't you just tell yourself like are you sure it just is very strange so it's sort of very different than a you know going on to google and searching for a blog post or a stack overflowflow. And so, yeah, I still not
一直问 AI 问题，但我确实认为它正在变好。好吧，这对我新闻故事的过渡非常好，那就是 DeepSeek 声称其推理模型在某些基准测试上击败了 OpenAI 的 O1。所以我这里有一个链接到 TechCrunch 的文章，但你所说的是完全正确的。所以你可以想象一个系统，每次你给它一个问题，它给你一个答案，然后你说：“你确定吗？那个答案看起来有点错。”然后它重新思考并给出了另一个答案。现在，假设如果你告诉它：“好吧，让我们假设从虚空中创建一个答案与基于过去答案创建一个答案相比，让我们假设后者比前者更好。”
long all of the, you know, asking AI the questions, but I do think it's getting better. Well, that is a great segue to my news story, which is DeepSeek claims its reasoning model beats OpenAI's O1 on certain benchmarks benchmarks and so i have an article linked to tech crunch here but you know what you said is exactly right and so you can imagine like imagine a system where every time you gave it a question it gave you an answer and then you said are you sure that answer looks kind of wrong and it went through and gives another answer um now let's assume that you know if you kind of like tell it okay so let's assume that creating an answer out of the ether versus creating an answer based off a past answer let's assume that the latter is better than the former on
总的来说。所以如果你能从这个早期的答案和投入其中的所有计算中受益，让我们假设你第二次可以写出更好的答案，对吧？所以现在这非常有趣，因为你实际上可以为自己创建训练数据……
aggregate. So if you have the benefit of this earlier answer and all the computation that went into it, let's assume that you could write a better answer the second time, right? So now that's really interesting because you can actually create training data for yourself
作为一个 AI。所以 AI 可以花两倍的时间回答一个问题，然后回去说：“嘿，那个花了双倍时间的答案，我想要那个答案。”所以它可以自我修复，像自我修复之类的东西。所以这不是一个新想法，你在游戏中就能看到这一点。例如，看看 AlphaGo，对吧？AlphaGo 会使用树搜索并模拟未来的棋盘，对吧？所以它可能会想：“哦，这一步很好，那一步也很好。”但随后它进行了大量的模拟，发现：“哦，只有第一步是好的。”
as an AI. So an AI could spend twice as long answering a question and then go back and say hey that that answer that took twice as long like i want that answer right away and so it can fix itself like self-healing kind of stuff and and so this is not a new idea like you see this with games so So for example, look at AlphaGo, right? So AlphaGo will use tree search and like simulate future boards, right? And so it might think, oh, this move is good and this move is good. But then it does a bunch of simulations and it finds, oh, only that first move is good.
另一个是垃圾。好吧，那是对那个必须做出瞬间判断的系统的反馈，对吧？所以这是将那个想法带入大语言模型领域。所以这是一个非常有趣的想法。现在，挑战变成了信用分配。所以有时候你会说：“嘿，多想想这个。”它照做了，但答案更糟，或者它产生更多的幻觉之类的。所以你……
The other one's trash. Well, like that's feedback to that first system that has to make that snap judgment, right? And so this is taking that idea and bringing it into the large language model space. And so a really interesting idea. Now, the challenge becomes credit assignment. So there are times where you say like hey think about this more and it does and the answer is worse or it's like more it's like hallucinates even more and stuff so you
仍然需要引导系统。只要你做出这种假设，即“第二个答案总是更好”，如果你想放松这一点或反驳这一点，你现在必须使用强化学习或其他技巧来引导系统。但 OpenAI 已经研究这个有一段时间了。让这件事变得非常有趣的是，DeepSeek 模型来自中国的一个量化金融研究实验室。我想如果我没记错这个故事的话，他们是在做量化之类的东西。我不是金融专家，Patrick，如果你觉得这不对，你可能会反驳我，但我猜这就像你在特定时间买卖东西，或者我不知道他们在做什么。所以突然之间，他们不得不……
have to craft uh you still need to guide the system um as long you know as long as you're making this assumption that just like every second answer is better you know if you want to relax that or push back on that now you have to guide the system using reinforcement learning as other tricks but um but so this so opening eyes been working on this for a while um the thing that makes this really interesting is the the deep seek model comes from a quant finance research lab in china that i think they were i get this story correctly you know they were like doing quant stuff and i'm not a finance guy patrick you're probably gonna like rip on me if this but i guess it's like you're buying and selling things at certain times or i don't know what they're doing so so then all of a sudden they like had to take
休息一下。有一些问题，有一些打压之类的。所以他们开始研究这些其他模型。他们制作了这个惊人的推理模型，它是完全免费的，源代码可用。唯一不可用的是他们用来训练模型的数据，我认为大多数模型都有这种封闭数据，但模型本身、权重是免费的，源代码是免费的，你可以微调它，你可以做所有这些事情。所以它确实是革命性的，我们得看看它会走向何方。
a break from that. There was some issue that there was some crackdown or something. And so they started working on some of these other models. And they produced this amazing reasoning model that's completely free, like source code available. The only thing that's not available is the data they use to train the model, is which is not uncommon i think most of these models have that uh closed data um but the model itself the weights are free the source code's free you can fine tune it you can do all these things and so uh it's really kind of revolutionary we'll have to see where it goes
说到信用，我忘了这是谁的想法，不是我的，但有人指出了这一点，我很感兴趣。所以你提到了像 AlphaGo。我认为非常有趣的一点是，最初 AlphaGo 是用所有的围棋游戏进行训练的，这是你谈到的引导，有一个胜负的框架，更好和更差，这与所有人类知识不同。但后来他们说：“哦，实际上我们删除了所有那些游戏，重新开始，并仅仅通过互相博弈来引导，从零开始弄清楚一切，没有那种锚定。”那个思想实验，人们谈论的想法是，我认为我们已经移动了球门柱，放弃了那种“我们如何确定 AI 是否是 AGI，或者它是否能愚弄人类”的判断标准。
this speaking of credit i've lost uh whose idea this was, not mine, but someone was pointing this out and I've been intrigued. So you mentioned sort of like AlphaGo. And I think one of the things that was really interesting is initially AlphaGo was trained with sort of, you know, all of the Go games that this is the guiding you're talking about there's a framework for winning and losing better and worse um which is sort of different from all human knowledge i guess but the and they kind of later said oh actually we've removed all of those games started again and bootstrapped with just playing each other and just like figuring it all out from scratch without without that anchoring and the the, I don't know, thought experiment, the idea people were talking about as like, I think we've sort of moved the goalposts, given up the sort of like, how do we determine if an AI is sort of like AGI or if it's able to fool a human,
一切都以一种与我们预想不同的方式发生了变化。所以这个讨论已经丢失了。但有人说的一个标志是，现在我们输入大量的数据，所有的维基百科，所有的 Stack Overflow，所有的互联网作为训练数据。如果相反，你回到过去说：“让我们获取 1900 年之前所有的书籍、报纸和研究，然后提出问题……”
like everything sort of shifts because things kind of became in a way that is different than we kind of thought they would. And so this discussion has been lost. But one of the things someone was saying as like a sort of marker would be right now we feed tons and tons of data, all of Wikipedia, all of Stack Overflow, all of the internet in as this training data. If instead you sort of went back and said, let's take all of the books and newspapers and research up to, you know, sort of 1900 and then sort of ask questions like
这些现象通常以量子物理学或广义相对论而闻名，一切都是通过思想实验写出来的，你可以提出很多这些想法和理论，并证明数学是有效的。后来我们回过头来解释那些发生的事情，要么是被误解的，要么是我们不知道的。所以你能给这些模型提供截止日期之前的一切吗？我们争论它，但如果你有一些实验结果，锁定它，并要求它进行思想实验，推进物理框架。你会得到量子力学吗？你会得到爱因斯坦的广义相对论吗？它们能够自我强化吗？
the phenomena were often known for sort of quantum physics or for general relativity like everything was written where you could via sort of thought experiment come up with a lot of these ideas and theories and show that the math worked and later we sort of back explained things that were happening that either were misascribed or that we didn't know. So could you give one of these models like everything up to end the date, you know, we kind of argue it, but where you have some of these experimental results, you know, kind of lock it and ask it to thought experiment forward sort of physics frameworks. And would you get quantum mechanics? Would you get Einstein's theory of general relativity? Would they be able to sort of self reinforce, right?
你需要几乎像你所说的那样，它们会写自己的论文，然后它们会将这些学习成果纳入其他学习成果中，也许是一个代理 AI，人们在采取不同的东西，这样它们就可以互相碰撞，无论解决方案是什么。但我认为我们今天还没到那一步，有两个原因：似乎所有这些模型仍然需要大量的训练数据，而不是很小的语料库。1900 年之前所有书面记录的数据只是今天输入这些模型的数据的一小部分。其次，我不认为有这种能力，也许我们正通过你所说的达到这一点，让这些东西拥有它们自己的模拟社会，并让它向前滚动，发现这些东西，学习它们并理解它们。所以当然，说它们可以运行自己的实验就更遥远了。我不知道，也许这很难，今天遥不可及。但我所描述的只是通过思想实验和深刻的内省思考，然后后来被实验证明，对吧？但感觉如果你有正确的架构系统训练，你可以做到这一点，但我们今天还没到那一步。
And you kind of need almost like what you're talking about, where they would write their own papers, then they would sort of incorporate those learnings into other learnings, maybe an agentic AI where people are taking different things, so they can kind of bounce off each other, whatever the solution is. But I don't think we're there today, for two reasons, like it seems still all of these models require just gobs and gobs of training data not very small corpuses all of the written recorded data up to 1900 is a very tiny fraction of what goes into these today um and then second of all i don't think there's this ability and i maybe we're getting there with what you're saying but to kind
是的，我想你是对的。我认为对于很多这些事情，它最终会像它真的放大了幻觉问题。就像：“哦，我看到这里有一个真理的核心，1+1 等于……”所以我们缺失的，我认为我们缺失的最大的基础东西是……
of roll forward to let these things sort of have their own simulated society and like roll it forward and discover these things and learn them and understand them um and so of course it's even further to say they could run their own experiments i you know maybe that's that's a lot harder and out of reach today but what i'm describing just sort of via thought experiments and sort of deep introspective thinking you know and then later it gets proven out by experiment right but it feels like you could do that if you had the right architecture system training but we're not there today yeah yeah i think you're right um yeah i i i think that with a lot of these things it'll end up like it really multiplies the hallucination problem. It's like, oh, I see there's a kernel of truth here that one plus one equals and so um what we're missing i think the big foundational thing we're missing is
我们的大脑中有非常强大的物理模型，这就是人们如何能击中时速 100 英里的棒球，对吧？我们在非常低的层面上拥有这些，比如初级视觉皮层，我相信音频和物理也有类似的东西，所有这些东西都是进化而来的，所以训练数据可以追溯到数百万年前，对吧？所以我认为那些模拟器，我们真的不知道如何将其插入 AI。我们只是从非常基础的东西开始。AI 会决定：“哦，这里剩下的是一个代数问题，我可以使用 Wolfram Alpha。”但在使用工具和拥有模拟器方面，这还处于非常早期的阶段……这是一个非常简单的……
like we have kind of really strong models in our brain of physics that's how people can like hit a baseball out flying 100 miles an hour right it's like we have these like at a really low level it's like primary visual cortex we have something similar i'm sure for audio and for physics all these things and they are evolved so the training data goes back millions of years right and so that's i think those kind of simulators you know we don't really know how to plug that into an AI. We're just starting with very basic things. The AI will decide, oh, what's left here is an algebra problem. I can use Wolfram Alpha. But that's very early days in using tools and having simulators that aren't... Here's a very simple
你可以运行的实验来证明这一点。如果你拍一张迷宫的照片，即使是一个任何孩子都能解决的非常简单的迷宫，你让 LLM 画一个 ASCII 艺术版本的迷宫，它将无法做到，它会完全失败。我认为原因是……你需要这种模拟器，当你画画时，你实际上是在回溯，你有一种空间概念，它独立于语言模型。现在这些都是即将到来的事情，但它们还没到那一步。哦，是的，好吧，这真的很有趣。我有一些后续想法，但我们不会永远卡在这里，否则我们永远讨论不了其他事情。但第一个是，我想，同样，不是我原创的，我认为 Yann LeCun 在他的一些采访中谈到了这一点，但生成式的东西而不是 LLM 的东西，它们最终需要一种理解。比如，我有一张一个人拿着球的照片……
experiment you can run to prove this to you. If you take a picture of of uh here's a very simple experiment you can run to prove this to you if you take a picture of a maze even a very simple maze that like any child could solve and you tell an llm to draw like an ascii art version of the maze like it won't be able to do that it will completely fail um and and i think the reason for that is um is that you need this kind of simulator where you kind of as you're drawing you're then kind of going back and like you have this like concept of spatial that's kind of independent of the language model um now these are all things that are coming but they're not there yet oh yeah okay that's really interesting i have a yeah a couple follow up thoughts but we we won't get stuck here forever or we'll never cover anything else. But the first one is, I think, and again, not original to me, I think Jan Lekun talks about this in some of his interviews, but the sort generation stuff rather than the llm stuff they end up needing an understanding like you know i have a picture of a guy holding a ball
我让你生成一个他扔球的视频。好吧，球每一帧应该掉落多远？这需要对物理、世界模型有一些理解。如果我把它向上扔呢？比如，一个投手正在投棒球，你要画一个抛物线吗？像这样上下起伏？那个物理学描述得很好，但它实际上并没有……它有关于人们投棒球的大量数据，但它从未被赋予投棒球的方程。你知道它需要遵循抛物线、半旋转，这种东西真的很有趣。但更直接地回到 DeepSeek 的事情，我确实看到人们发布了一些与……
and i ask you to generate a video of him dropping it right well how far should the ball drop each frame requires some understanding about physics about world money what if i throw it up right like hey the a pitcher is throwing a baseball are you going to draw in a sort of parabola right like this up and down that physics is well described but it doesn't actually it has gobs of data about people throwing baseballs but it's never been given the equation for throwing a baseball you know that it needs to follow a parabola half spin you know this kind of stuff is really interesting um but then more directly into to the deep seek thing i guess is i did see people posting some of the you know interactions with
DeepSeek 的互动，以及你谈到的臭名昭著的“草莓里有几个 r”。所以有人问 DeepSeek：“草莓里有几个 r？”它陷入了这种与自己争论的循环中。它就像：“好吧，让我们列出字母：S、T、R，哦，有一个；A、W，它到了第二个 R；R，到了第三个 R，它就像：‘哦，不，有一个错误，我知道应该有两个 R，但我刚才数了三个。等等，让我们再试一次。’”所以它又试了一次，又试了一次。所以它一直保持着这种……就像你说的，一个核心，它在做正确的事情，它知道如何计数，知道如何争论，但它在计数，这是正确的，但它也以某种方式……拥有这个……
deep seek and what you're talking about the infamous how many r's are in strawberry so somebody asked deep seek you know how many how many r's are in strawberry and it gets stuck in this arguing with itself loop like it's like well let's list out the letters s t r oh there's one a w it gets to the second r r gets to the third r it's like uh-oh there's a mistake i know they're supposed to be two r's but i just counted three uh wait a minute let's try it again and so like it goes again and it tries to go again and again so like it keeps getting to this like you said a kernel like it's doing the correct thing it knows how to count knows how is arguable but it like it's doing counting which is correct but then it also somehow like has this
关于DeepSeek以及你提到的那个臭名昭著的“strawberry里有几个r”的问题。有人问DeepSeek“strawberry里有几个r”，结果它陷入了一种自我争论的循环。它就像是说：“好吧，让我们列出这些字母：s-t-r，哦，有一个；a-w……”然后数到第二个r，再数到第三个r，它就觉得：“噢，不对，出错了。我知道应该有两个r，但我刚才数出了三个。等等，让我再试一次。”于是它又重新开始，一遍又一遍地尝试。就像你说的，它陷入了一个核心逻辑，它在做正确的事——它知道怎么数数，虽然“知道怎么数”还有待商榷，但它确实在进行计数，这本身是正确的，但不知为何它又陷入了这种状态。
belief that the answer is two which you know several llms seem to have gotten stuck with this for whatever reason source grounded that strawberry has two r's and because of that like it sort of goes wait a minute i must have miscounted i must have done an algorithm i wasn't supposed to do so then it tries you know variance on counting basically keeps coming up with the answer three and going but that's wrong and so it's just this very fascinating like clearly the answer is three you could ask anyone but like it it kind of can't do it it's just it's just it's like oh it just killed over and died yeah yeah totally yeah i mean this is like it needs like a roving eye that can like rove like over all the different letters um and and it needs to be able to do that kind of explicitly instead of implicitly and we're just not there yet
相信答案是二，你知道，出于某种原因，几个大语言模型似乎都卡在这里了。源头认为 strawberry 有两个 r，正因如此，它就像是说“等一下，我肯定数错了，我肯定用了不该用的算法”，所以它尝试了各种计数变体，基本上一直得出答案是三，然后又觉得“不对，那是错的”。这非常迷人，显然答案是三，你可以问任何人，但它就是做不到，就像是……哦，它直接死机了。是的，完全是这样。我的意思是，它需要一个能像眼睛一样扫视所有不同字母的机制，而且它需要显式地而不是隐式地做到这一点，但我们还没达到那个水平。
all right well my my next uh news article is not directly in this uh but but it is a bit on topic i guess and that is a list of computer science papers every developer should read i'm apologizing i won't attempt to pronounce the author's name dr well i guess i'll try to say the last name do you are you able to say this jason or you want me to go? Milan Milanovic. Okay. Yeah, I was going to say the same thing. Dr. Milanovic. And he wrote this blog post. The link's in the show notes. It's a lengthy link.
好的，我的下一篇新闻文章不直接相关，但我想多少有点关联，那就是一份每个开发者都应该阅读的计算机科学论文清单。我很抱歉，我不会尝试读这位作者的名字，博士……好吧，我想我会试着读一下姓氏。你能读出来吗，Jason，还是你想让我来？Milan Milanovic。好的。是的，我正想说这个。Milanovic 博士。他写了这篇博文。链接在节目说明里。这是一个很长的链接。
And the papers here listed, I don't have strong opinions about these specific papers. But he kind of goes into a defense of why developers should read academic papers now i guess this is going to expose a bit of a difference between jason's practice of computer science and my practice of computer science but in the kind of work that i do with largely embedded folks you know application programming reading academic papers is a it doesn't happen um most folks probably didn't do it in university they don't do it now they it's just a foreign thing and we've talked about this on on the show from time to time but i guess i will say that i think it can be a bit people overuse it but a bit of a superpower if you're in a role where no one reads academic
至于这里列出的论文，我对这些特定的论文没有强烈的看法。但他算是为“为什么开发者现在应该阅读学术论文”做了一番辩护。我想这会暴露 Jason 的计算机科学实践和我之间的差异，但在我主要与嵌入式人员合作的工作中，你知道，应用编程，阅读学术论文这种情况根本不会发生。大多数人可能在大学里没读过，现在也不读，这简直是件陌生的事情。我们时不时会在节目中讨论这个问题，但我还是要说，我认为这可以成为一种“超能力”，虽然人们有时会过度使用这个词，但如果你身处一个没人阅读学术论文的岗位，而你愿意在需要时尝试去阅读，
papers and you're willing to at least try to read academic papers when when the need arises going around and saying oh there's this new research paper that says you know this and we're going to do it probably not the right answer but saying oh hey people must have had this problem before people must have you know worked on this issue and just doing a literature search is kind of what i would call it, often turns up via academic papers or whatever. And you would be floored at the number of people who won't just search for something. Hey, I'm stuck on this hard problem. I need an optimization of this nature. And they just won't sort of, well, we're just talking about AI, maybe that'll be the future, but they won't just shove it into Google and try to like spend a few minutes sifting through this.
四处说“哦，有篇新研究论文说了这个，我们要照做”，这可能不是正确的答案，但说“哦，嘿，人们以前肯定遇到过这个问题，人们肯定研究过这个问题”，然后做一次文献检索——我称之为文献检索——通常会通过学术论文或其他资料找到答案。你会惊讶于有多少人甚至不去搜索一下。嘿，我被这个难题卡住了。我需要这种性质的优化。他们就是不会……好吧，我们刚才在谈论人工智能，也许那会是未来，但他们就是不会把它扔进谷歌，花几分钟筛选一下。
It's not going to give you a Stack Over stack overflow answer but you might find a paper where someone has looked at that hey optimizations uh cash efficiency of various hash map styles whatever it might be and so i will agree with with the doctor here say oh i guess we don't say it that way because that makes it sound like a medical doctor anyways but the author of this blog post uh and sort of say that i think you should try to read a few papers um i will be honest whenever i read a paper 90 of it is is it just like one year out the other like i either can't decipher what they're saying or can't understand it but even just reading a few of it looking at the pictures start to pick it up if you do one or two of those you will start to glean the gist and then either
它不会给你一个 Stack Overflow 的现成答案，但你可能会找到一篇论文，有人研究过那个问题，比如各种哈希映射风格的缓存效率等等。所以我同意这位博士的观点——哦，我想我们不该那样说，因为那听起来像医学博士——总之，这位博文作者的观点，我认为你应该试着读几篇论文。老实说，每当我读论文时，90% 的内容都是左耳进右耳出，要么是我无法解读他们在说什么，要么是无法理解。但即使只是读一点，看看图片，开始领会其中的意思，如果你读了一两篇，你就会开始掌握要点，然后要么
going and giving you the next thing to go search or writing it it really is for certain problems just such a like 10x ability to to kind of like execute on it and i'm not talking about papers that were written this year or last year in this journal i'm talking about like 1980s you know the you know 2000s that there were these papers written and you'll find them and it's just like wow that's yeah this is this is this is great this is exactly what i needed or gives somebody a you know like hey there's backup that i'm not crazy doing this like this is a well thought through thing and in some corners of the universe yeah totally um so yeah i mean i've read probably two to three papers a week for 25 years so i've
去寻找下一个搜索目标，要么去实践它。对于某些问题，这确实是一种十倍的执行能力。我说的不是今年或去年发表在期刊上的论文，我说的是 1980 年代、2000 年代的那些论文。你会发现它们，然后感叹“哇，这太棒了，这正是我所需要的”，或者给某人提供支持，证明“我做这个并不是疯了，这是一个经过深思熟虑的事情”。在宇宙的某些角落，确实如此。所以，是的，我 25 年来大概每周读两到三篇论文，所以我
read a lot of papers um i've actually read most of the papers you posted which i feel like is hey good for you considering like it's not these aren't really my fields per se uh actually this out of the tar pit sounds really interesting um uh folks can check all the show notes on the whatever app you're using to listen to the show the notes should be there or you can go to programming throwdown.com but yeah these papers are amazing like mapperdu's big table kafka um i will say to read a paper well typically it's good to you know you read the abstract because it's the first thing um and then i go straight to um uh well i'll read the introduction if i'm not already motivated you know the introduction is there to kind of motivate the idea um depending on kind of like the first few lines of introduction i may or may not skip it but i'll go to the background um and see like okay
读过很多论文。我其实读过你发布的大部分论文，我觉得这……嘿，考虑到这些并不是我的专业领域，你做得不错。其实这篇《走出泥潭》（Out of the Tar Pit）听起来很有趣。大家可以在你用来收听节目的任何应用中查看节目说明，说明应该在那里，或者你可以访问 programmingthrowdown.com。但这些论文太棒了，比如 MapReduce、BigTable、Kafka。我会说，要读好一篇论文，通常最好先读摘要，因为那是第一部分，然后我直接跳到……好吧，如果我还没有动力，我会读引言，引言是为了激发对这个想法的兴趣。根据引言的前几行，我可能会也可能不会跳过它，但我会去看背景，看看……好吧，
are is this standing on a foundation that i know like if i start reading the background um and see like okay are is this standing on a foundation that i know like if i start reading the background it's like we all know about uyosaka method and i'm like uh-oh like okay i guess i have to go read that one um if it seems like i can like more or less understand the background i'll actually skip the main like contribution of the paper and go straight to the results and typically in the results there'll be some other method that i know and that will really help even just knowing what they compared with like i'll go straight to the table of the results it's like okay you know they compared with like several different actor critic policies so this must be another actor-critic policy,
这是否建立在我所知的知识基础上？如果我开始读背景，看到“我们都知道 Uyosaka 方法”，我会想“噢，不，好吧，看来我得去读读那个”。如果我觉得我或多或少能理解背景，我实际上会跳过论文的主要贡献部分，直接去看结果。通常在结果中会有一些我所知的其他方法，这真的很有帮助，即使只是知道他们与什么进行了比较。我会直接看结果表格，比如“好的，他们与几种不同的 Actor-Critic 策略进行了比较，所以这一定也是一种 Actor-Critic 策略”。
these kind of things. And then I'll look at the results. And they'll also give me an idea like, if this is like a 16-page paper and it's like 0.02% better than some other method, well, it kind of tempers my expectations, right? And then I'll go back and read the method so you kind of have to like go in that order i think it is a learned skill i mean i think like what jason's
诸如此类的事情。然后我会看结果。它们也会给我一个概念，比如如果这是一篇 16 页的论文，而它只比其他方法好 0.02%，嗯，这会降低我的期望，对吧？然后我会回去读方法部分，所以我觉得你必须按那个顺序来。我认为这是一种习得的技能。我的意思是，我认为像 Jason
saying i mean to be fair i've read maybe three to five papers a year um that's i guess maybe i'm gonna shame myself but whatever uh it is it does take time and and it is not uh at least for me not just like i'll pick it up and do it there's a there's a technique to it and you do learn that they're written in a certain way and you know it sometimes does take two or three in the same sort of corner um to to kind of get get and then you go back and i think that's the other thing is it's not like a blog post you can kind of read it once and get it i think in my in my thing at least you kind of skim it look at the pictures kind of get where you're going and you might go back and then as you sort of figured out you might go back again um and as silly as it sounds even in this day like printing it out and for whatever reason like actually having it in
所说的那样……公平地说，我一年大概读三到五篇论文。我想我可能要为自己感到羞愧，但不管怎样，这确实需要时间，而且对我来说，至少不是那种拿起来就能读的东西。这有一套技巧，你会发现它们是以某种方式编写的，而且你知道，有时在同一个领域需要读两三篇才能理解。然后你再回去看，我认为这是另一回事，它不像博客文章，你读一遍就能懂。至少对我来说，你会先略读，看看图片，大致了解方向，然后你可能会回去看，当你弄清楚了一些东西，你可能会再次回去看。而且，听起来可能很傻，即使在今天，把它打印出来，出于某种原因，实际把它拿在
front of me this is literally the only thing i ever print out anymore but i will print out a paper if i'm really trying to get through it and like holding it and sort of like being able to see two pages at once or, you know, or mark on something or like, you know, circle something I want to come back to. I never do that for anything else,
我面前……这实际上是我唯一会打印的东西，但如果我真的想读懂一篇论文，我会把它打印出来，拿着它，能够同时看到两页，或者在上面做标记，或者圈出我想回头看的内容。我从不为其他任何东西这样做，
but when I do papers, it, it, you know, it helps me. Yeah. I used to print it out and now I use my, the ink tablet.
但当我读论文时，它确实有帮助。是的，我过去也打印出来，现在我用我的墨水屏平板电脑。
Um, and then you could just draw with the with the pencil um man i mean this is okay we're going into into a bunch of side talks here but it'd be amazing if someone made why hasn't someone just made a ink tablet that's the size of a u.s sheet of paper like why is that so hard money i i will pay for that uh you have an you have one person who will buy that um maybe there's some technical thing too i don't know like maybe like making an ink tablet that's that big is probably yeah i would also i mean i guess like once you add in the other stuff maybe it's like difficult to fit into your backpack or something like, you know, and so therefore people,
嗯，然后你可以直接用笔在上面画。天哪，我们现在进入了一堆题外话，但如果有人制造出……为什么还没人制造出像美国信纸大小的墨水屏平板电脑？为什么那么难？钱的问题。我会为此买单的。你有一个会买的人。也许还有一些技术上的原因，我不知道，比如制造那么大的墨水屏平板电脑可能……是的，我也觉得，一旦你加上其他东西，可能就很难放进背包之类的，所以因此人们……
I would assume most people buying them are reading fiction, you know, novels, and those fit really well on a relatively small screen and just flow, data just flow, the words just flow around, right? I would assume that's, whatever, 95% of the hours spent on eating tablets are spent doing that and so i think today they sort of cluster around the size of a paperback yeah i think that makes a lot of sense there's an amazing thing uh if folks i don't know if this is on iphone it probably is but if you have adobe acrobat on android they have this thing called liquid mode where it takes like the paper and turns it into kind of like that format where you can scale the text and read as you know what I mean.
我假设大多数购买它们的人是在读小说，你知道，那些在相对较小的屏幕上非常合适，而且文字只是流动，数据只是流动，文字在周围流动，对吧？我假设那是……不管怎样，在墨水屏平板电脑上花费的 95% 的时间都是在做那个，所以我认为今天它们大多集中在平装书的大小。是的，我觉得这很有道理。有一个很棒的东西，如果大家……我不知道这在 iPhone 上有没有，可能有的，但如果你在安卓上有 Adobe Acrobat，他们有一个叫“液态模式”（Liquid Mode）的功能，它会把论文变成那种你可以缩放文字并阅读的格式，你知道我的意思吗？
It basically takes the PDF and turns it into a format that's awesome for mobile and it usually doesn't mess up the diagrams and all that. That feels like a low hanging AI target right there, which is like take this PDF and and make it like you know whatever i don't know what they call that yeah flowable liquid like yeah yeah yeah but like good i've seen so many bad where people it just like it's broken and doesn't work right yeah yeah same um all right my article is my second is nvidia cosmos an ai platform to change the future of robots and cars, wins best of CES. So that's a pretty bold subtitle there. But what is that? Anyways, the thing where you kind of put a title in the middle of the title.
它基本上把 PDF 变成了适合移动设备的格式，而且通常不会弄乱图表之类的。这感觉像是一个低垂的人工智能目标，就是把这个 PDF 变成……你知道，不管他们叫什么，是的，是的，流式液态，但要好用。我见过很多糟糕的例子，人们把它弄坏了，无法正常工作。是的，我也是。好的，我的第二篇文章是《Nvidia Cosmos：一个改变机器人和汽车未来的 AI 平台，荣获 CES 最佳奖》。这是一个相当大胆的副标题。但那是什么？总之，那种在标题中间放标题的做法。
But Cosmos is really interesting, and it ties into what Patrick was saying. It is a world foundation model and so the idea is people have uh people at nvidia have um taken you know like videos and tried to predict the future of the video and they've done other things like that what you end up with is something that the world foundation model is trying to be kind of like a physics simulator um to try to give you like an idea of what's going to happen in the future and then what you can do is take embeddings which are like you know compressed vector representations of images you can take like the embeddings of the future and feed them into a model and so the idea is if you have a robot the robot might know that like hey uh you know this future looks pretty weird like this future looks like it's the kind of future of a robot that's
但 Cosmos 真的很有趣，它与 Patrick 所说的相呼应。它是一个世界基础模型，所以想法是 Nvidia 的人们获取了视频，并试图预测视频的未来，他们还做了其他类似的事情。你最终得到的是一个世界基础模型，它试图成为一种物理模拟器，试图让你对未来会发生什么有一个概念。然后你可以做的是获取嵌入（embeddings），也就是图像的压缩向量表示，你可以获取未来的嵌入并将其输入模型。所以想法是，如果你有一个机器人，机器人可能会知道“嘿，这个未来看起来很奇怪，这个未来看起来像是一个机器人
falling down the stairs and so i'm just gonna stop because i don't like where this is going right um and so the idea is you can combine these world models with like some like uh inertial data and all of that to like make robotics a lot easier um you know nothing practical has come out of it um but i think that i think it's it's something really interesting and i think that it's it's it's going it's skating where the puck is going i just don't know uh what's going to happen there there were a lot of really interesting we didn't put them in here but nvidia announcements so i i mean i think for sake of time we'll just skip them but if you haven't gone and looked at
从楼梯上摔下来的未来，所以我现在要停下来，因为我不喜欢事情发展的方向”。所以想法是，你可以将这些世界模型与一些惯性数据结合起来，让机器人技术变得容易得多。你知道，目前还没有什么实际的应用出来，但我认为这非常有趣，而且我认为它是在“滑向冰球要去的地方”。我只是不知道会发生什么。有很多非常有趣的……我们没有把它们放进来，但 Nvidia 的公告……所以为了节省时间，我们就不提了，但如果你还没有去看看
the various things that nvidia is doing and introduced and you're vaguely interested in ai and and how the the underlying hardware is, is, you know, shifting, I would definitely go. There's some like, what do they call those? Like super cut, like where they cut up the sort of CEO speech and sort of like show you the highlights. Yeah.
Nvidia 正在做和推出的各种事情，而且你对人工智能以及底层硬件如何转变略感兴趣，我绝对会去看看。他们有那种……他们叫什么来着？超级剪辑（super cut），就是他们剪辑 CEO 的演讲并展示重点。是的。
I've never heard of that. I think so. Instead of, you know, watching an hour keynote or whatever you watch, you know, five minutes, 10 minutes.
我从没听说过那个。我想是吧。而不是看一小时的主题演讲，你只看五分钟、十分钟。
I did that on the one from Google last year, and it was just Sundar Pichai saying generative ai over and over again but then you realized it was a generative ai video it wasn't actually him all right time for book of the show book of the show patrick what's your book okay completely out of character for me but whatever and it ties back a bit to what i was saying trying to to kind of read sort of more academic approach and broad broadened my horizons i'll call it but this is alice's adventures in a differentiable wonderland which i haven't made it all the way through yet it's a little slow going for me um but it is i
我去年看了谷歌的那场，结果全是 Sundar Pichai 一遍又一遍地说“生成式 AI”，但后来你意识到那是一个生成式 AI 视频，那根本不是他本人。好了，节目书单时间。节目书单，Patrick，你的书是什么？好的，这完全不符合我的性格，但不管怎样，它与我刚才说的有点联系，尝试以更学术的方式阅读并拓宽我的视野。我称之为《爱丽丝梦游微分仙境》（Alice's Adventures in a Differentiable Wonderland），我还没读完，对我来说进展有点慢，但它
think so far it has been like a little bit of an in-between machine learning book so you can get the sort of like elementary takes which i feel like i i kind of get i think a lot of people are out there sort of understand that you know high conceptual 30 000 foot level what's going on with you know the machine learning and more than just you know oh it's an llm like okay well there's you know convolutional layers and there's you know there's this this you maybe watched uh you know the three blue one brown always mess up his name video about lms and transformers and how they work right like you sort of understand some of the the nuts and bolts from i'll call it like the top down to about the middle um and you know you may even could run
我认为到目前为止，它是一本介于中间的机器学习书，所以你可以获得那种基础的理解，我觉得我大概懂了。我认为很多人在外面理解那种高概念的 3 万英尺视角，了解机器学习正在发生什么，不仅仅是“哦，它是一个大语言模型”。好吧，你知道有卷积层，有这个，你可能看了 3Blue1Brown 的视频——我总是记错他的名字——关于大语言模型和 Transformer 以及它们是如何工作的，对吧？你从我所说的“自上而下”到中间部分，了解了一些基本原理。而且你甚至可以运行
python scripts to train your own little little model stuff stuff i've done but then if you flip it around and go sort of like bottom up you know jason was describing this earlier like how do you vectorize this thing i want to do and build models like how do you start to piece together these things why do they work what is the expectation um and then the thing that for a long time has eluded me and is maybe clued in by the title here is these you know ways of combining the math operation so that they're differentiable and what does that mean and that's basically how you get the training how you take an effectively random set of numbers and guide them into weights that actually evoke a certain you know output i'm probably using the wrong words here but that's because i'm not trained and so this book seems to be a pretty middle of the road just what i'm trying
Python 脚本来训练你自己的小模型，这些我都做过。但如果你把它翻过来，从“自下而上”开始，你知道 Jason 刚才描述的那样，你如何向量化这个东西，我想做并构建模型，你如何开始拼凑这些东西，它们为什么有效，期望是什么？然后，长期以来一直困扰我，并且可能被书名暗示的是，这些结合数学运算的方法，使它们可微，这意味着什么？这基本上就是你如何进行训练，你如何获取一组有效的随机数字，并将它们引导成真正能产生特定输出的权重。我可能用了错误的词，那是因为我没有受过训练。所以这本书似乎是一本相当中规中矩的书，我正试图
to get through it it doesn't not use any formulas but it's also trying to explain what they're doing and where they're going if you just jump into one of the the papers you know transformers are all you need or whatever oh no that's not the name anyways um the you know you get this sort of like immediate dumping into like way too much context that i don't have um and so this this book it's a book but it's free it's you know published in a pdf i think you can go buy a physical copy as well but i have a link in the show notes to where you can find it sort of kind of takes you through the various things i'll say sort of bottoms up in this sort of middle of the road probably someone who has a math background who knows computer science but isn't a machine learning person and is trying to
读完它。它并非不使用任何公式，但它也试图解释它们在做什么以及要去向何方。如果你只是跳进其中一篇论文，比如《Attention Is All You Need》或者其他什么……哦不，那不是那个名字。总之，你会被立即丢进太多我没有的背景知识中。所以这本书，它是一本书，但它是免费的，它以 PDF 格式发布，我想你也可以买实体书，但我有一个链接在节目说明里，你可以找到它。它以某种方式引导你完成各种事情，我称之为“自下而上”，处于这种中规中矩的水平，可能适合那些有数学背景、懂计算机科学但不是机器学习专业人士，并且试图
learn more than just here's the PyTorch commands you run, but here's what the PyTorch commands are doing or why they're doing it. What is the motivation here, which is a big gap in where I am. So I'll take that maybe right or wrong assumption that if if i'm struggling with that maybe other people are as well and since someone wrote a book clearly i guess yeah this is awesome motivation there so yeah this is so cool i mean this is a what a 300 page book totally for free yeah yeah yeah this is amazing yeah highly recommend it um i'm very cool okay you got me hooked on this i'm gonna have to read this now he's gonna ask the ai can you read it to me please yeah i'm gonna have an ai read this to me now um okay my
学习的不仅仅是“这是你运行的 PyTorch 命令”，而是“这些 PyTorch 命令在做什么，或者为什么要这样做”。这里的动机是什么？这在我目前的知识体系中是一个巨大的空白。所以我可能会做出一个正确或错误的假设：如果我在为此挣扎，也许其他人也是如此。既然有人写了这本书，显然……是的，这真是太棒的动力了。所以，是的，这太酷了。我的意思是，这是一本 300 页的书，完全免费。是的，这太棒了。强烈推荐。嗯，太酷了。好的，你让我入坑了，我现在必须读这本书了。他会问 AI：“你能帮我读一下吗，拜托。”是的，我现在要让 AI 帮我读这本书。好的，我的
book of the show is a movie um this is also totally out of left field i mean you thought yours was out of left field wait till you hear this it's a beautiful Day in the Neighborhood, the movie about Mr. Rogers. And yeah, it's a really deep movie. I actually thought it was going to be a biography, but it's not. It's a fiction movie that's based on a true story of a reporter. The reporter was basically trying to write a smear piece about mr rogers you know one of these like muckraker kind of reporters and he follows mr rogers around mr rogers like actually like uh um gave him permission to like you know follow him around and interview him and all this and uh and he ends up like uh you know like like changing his life
节目书单是一部电影。这也完全出乎意料。我的意思是，你以为你的出乎意料，等听完这个再说。它是《邻里美好的一天》（A Beautiful Day in the Neighborhood），关于罗杰斯先生的电影。是的，这是一部非常深刻的电影。我实际上以为它会是一部传记片，但并不是。这是一部基于一位记者的真实故事改编的虚构电影。这位记者基本上试图写一篇关于罗杰斯先生的抹黑文章，你知道，那种像“扒粪者”一样的记者。他跟踪罗杰斯先生，罗杰斯先生实际上允许他跟踪并采访自己，所有这些……然后他最终……你知道，改变了他的人生，
and everything it's a really really touching movie um and uh yeah i highly recommend it i think is is pretty pretty wild actually totally blew my mind i'm generally more into like uh you know documentaries like i saw the um the one Queen, the documentary about the band Queen. I saw another one. Oh, the one about Theranos. I think it's called The Dropout. I saw that. I went to this one
以及一切。这是一部非常非常感人的电影，我强烈推荐它。我认为这实际上相当疯狂，完全震撼了我。我通常更喜欢纪录片，比如我看了关于皇后乐队的纪录片《Queen》。我还看了另一部。哦，关于 Theranos 的那部。我想它叫《辍学者》（The Dropout）。我看了那个。我去看这一部时，
just expecting another documentary, but my mind was completely blown by this movie. It's on Hulu, Netflix, all that good stuff um highly recommend you check it out i never watched documentary i guess i should if it says documentary i'm like i'm basically like instant out like i just for whatever reason i don't know i should probably watch them more instead of just like whatever i i don't know it's just like for me
只是期待另一部纪录片，但我的思想被这部电影完全震撼了。它在 Hulu、Netflix 上都有，所有那些好东西。强烈推荐你去看看。我从不看纪录片，我想如果它说是纪录片，我基本上会立刻拒绝。我不知道为什么，我可能应该多看一些，而不是只看……我不知道，对我来说，
i always feel like i'm gonna have to do a lot of follow-up work after this documentary to like, like understand the other side or whatever, because it always is sort of a hot take. Right. And so, um, yeah, I mean, you know, I think the, the ones that I've watched have been maybe not too controversial. I mean, like the queen one, for example, it's just really interesting, like how they came up with the songs they did and so it's really like i think it's a way for you to have been somewhere that you weren't you know like i wasn't in the studio when they were recording their songs but somebody was and they they provided insight and you get you get that kind of experience i guess like uh through through that so i will say the most impressive thing is that you said the title without any hint of
我总觉得看完纪录片后我得做很多后续工作，去理解另一面什么的，因为它总是一种“热点观点”。对吧。所以，嗯，你知道，我想我看过的那些可能不是太有争议。我的意思是，比如皇后乐队的那部，它只是非常有趣，关于他们是如何创作出那些歌曲的。所以我认为这是一种让你去过你没去过的地方的方式。你知道，比如他们录制歌曲时我不在录音室，但有人在，他们提供了见解，你通过那种方式获得了那种体验。所以我不得不说，最令人印象深刻的是，你说了片名，但声音里没有任何唱腔。哦天哪，看这部电影绝对是一种怀旧，因为你小时候看罗杰斯先生吗？是的，我也是。那太棒了。好的。好的。你的节目工具是什么？节目工具，它不是工具，它是一个游戏，
sing song in your voice. Oh man, it's definitely a throwback to watch because did you watch Mr. Rogers growing up? Yeah, me too. It was great. Okay. Yeah. All right. What is your tool of the show? Tool of show it's not a tool it is a game
所以它会浪费你的时间。我不建议你玩这个游戏。
so it will waste your time i would not recommend you to play this game um you wasted so much of my time on bellatro by the way i finally i i beat uh i think all the chips or i'm on the last chip oh you're better than me i got the red and black so good and then i the red and black deck is so stacked i mean you just have flushes whenever you want yeah okay people are like what um don't download that definitely don't yeah save your time yeah i have i have i have made it so that i'm only allowed to play that game when i'm on an airplane that's smart so otherwise it's it's bad for me uh okay this one's not quite so bad this is actually relatively really short game i guess they call these like incremental games um but someone threw
你浪费了我太多时间在《Balatro》上，顺便说一句，我终于……我想我打败了所有的筹码，或者我正在打最后一个筹码。哦，你比我强，我拿到了红黑牌，太棒了。然后红黑牌组太强了，我的意思是，你想要同花顺时就有。是的，好的，人们会说“什么……”，别下载那个，绝对别下载。是的，节省你的时间。是的，我已经设定好，只有在飞机上时才允许自己玩那个游戏。那很聪明，否则对我来说太糟糕了。好的，这个没那么糟糕，这实际上是一个相对非常短的游戏，我想他们称之为“增量游戏”，但有人抛出了
this out the other one that really killed a ton of my time was vampire survivors there's like it must be a whole thing i don't want to know please don't send me emails please um but like three dollar steam games or whatever so this is like a $3 steam game supposed to be short, just goofy. Um, but it's, it's digsium and, um,
这个，另一个真正浪费了我大量时间的是《吸血鬼幸存者》（Vampire Survivors）。这一定是一整套东西，我不想知道，请别给我发邮件，拜托。但就像 3 美元的 Steam 游戏之类的。所以这是一个 3 美元的 Steam 游戏，应该是短小的，只是傻乎乎的。嗯，它是《Digsium》，而且，
on a computer, you know, use a mouse and keyboard on my steam deck. It actually works really great. A lot of the, you know, sort of like clicker games kind of don't work great on your, on your,
在电脑上，你知道，我在我的 Steam Deck 上用鼠标和键盘。它实际上运行得非常好。很多那种点击类游戏在你的……在你的
you know, steam deck if, if you have one. Um, but this one I did this, I've been playing. It actually works really great. Do you have a touchscreen on the steam deck?
Steam Deck 上运行得不太好，如果你有的话。嗯，但这个我玩了，它实际上运行得非常好。你的 Steam Deck 有触摸屏吗？
Yes. Okay. And that's, that's what makes this game particularly so uh problematic for me which is uh the idea is you're kind of like I don't even know the story it's like you're running a museum and you're going out to these various fields and digging up relics to put in your museum and you get money for the visitors who come to museum it's all in not even 8-bit graphics like commodore 64 kind of like like graphics um but you have the various places you go to harvest relics uh increase in size and increase in the difficulty of of mining up the dirt and you'll have only so much energy to to kind of mine it up so if you're not able to sort of mine up all the blocks you could not get all the relics that were buried in that particular round. But everything is like very quick, you know, it's maybe five seconds to sort of tap, tap, tap, tap, or click, click, click, you know, clear the field,
是的。好的，这就是让这个游戏对我来说特别成问题的点，也就是……想法是你有点像……我甚至不知道故事是什么，就像你在经营一家博物馆，你到这些不同的田野去挖掘文物放进你的博物馆，你从来到博物馆的游客那里赚钱。它甚至不是 8 位图形，而是像 Commodore 64 那种图形。但你有各种地方可以去收获文物，挖掘泥土的规模和难度会增加，你只有有限的能量去挖掘它。所以如果你不能挖出所有的方块，你就不能得到埋在那一轮里的所有文物。但一切都非常快，你知道，可能五秒钟就能点点点，或者点点点，清理场地，
whatever run out of energy, you go again, you go again. And then you're also building up money in the background. And the classic, I guess, guess like incremental thing you can buy upgrades and then you can reboot you know yourself but some of the upgrades are permanent and you get for how high you get you get sort of permanent upgrade points that you can use before you start again and it's just like i know it's such a distillation of some of these incremental games either for me they just like have this plateau you get to and oh that's the that's the grind and it's amazing yeah i hate the grind yeah i got that at work i just wanted to be like like uh i was gonna say something it's not i guess i won't say what i was gonna it's just very like i just wanted
不管怎样，能量耗尽了，你就再去，再去。然后你在后台也在积累金钱。经典的，我想是增量游戏的东西，你可以购买升级，然后你可以重启你自己，但有些升级是永久的，你得到的升级点数取决于你挖得有多高，你可以在重新开始之前使用这些永久升级点数。这就像……我知道，这是这些增量游戏的一种提炼，对我来说，它们只是有一个你到达的平台，哦，那就是苦差事，这太棒了。是的，我讨厌苦差事。是的，我在工作中也遇到过，我只是想……我本来想说点什么，但我想我还是不说了，它只是非常……我只是想
to be light and very you know just a soda junk food kind of like get me through it i don't need it to be long lasting i don't need it to be thoughtful i just want to go full steam ahead and feel like i'm powerful yeah totally yeah totally. Yeah. This sounds awesome. This is right up my alley. So yeah, dig Xeum. I don't know if we said it, but yeah, it's available on steam and I don't know where else I tried looking. It didn't look like there was other places, but definitely it's available there. It's like three bucks. Maybe it goes on sale sometimes. Don't know. I just paid $3 and don't do that. It's just as real. You'll regret it. sometimes. Don't know. I just paid $3 and don't do that. It's just real.
轻松一点，你知道，就像垃圾食品一样，让我度过难关。我不需要它长久，我不需要它深思熟虑，我只想全速前进，感觉自己很强大。是的，完全是这样。是的，完全是这样。这听起来太棒了。这正合我意。所以，是的，《Digsium》。我不知道我们有没有说，但是的，它在 Steam 上有售，我不知道还有哪里有。我试着找过，看起来没有其他地方，但绝对可以在那里买到。大概三块钱。也许有时会打折。不知道。我只是付了 3 美元，别那样做。它就像真的。你会后悔的。有时。不知道。我只是付了 3 美元，别那样做。它就像真的。
You'll regret it. You'll spend, it's actually not that long, but you know, you'll just burn a bunch of time and you'll be like, what is it? There is an ending, right? I believe so. I, I think I'm pretty close. People told me how many hours they typically spent on it. Like when I, that's how I found it, you know, via some random link I saw somewhere. And I think I've about played that hours and so
你会后悔的。你会花……它实际上没那么长，但你知道，你会烧掉一堆时间，然后你会想，这是什么？它有一个结局，对吧？我相信是的。我……我想我快到了。人们告诉我他们通常在上面花了多少小时。就像我……我就是那样找到它的，通过我在某处看到的某个随机链接。我想我已经玩了那么多小时了，所以
i do get the feeling that i'm towards the end but i don't actually know so got it cool um my tool of the show is a python library called sequel light dict uh which is a weird name it's you know based on the dictionary uh object in python so so everyone doing Python has thought about this, where you have Python, you know, everything's a dictionary. Classes are dictionaries. All the objects are dictionaries. Data classes are dictionaries. So dictionary is like a really foundational object, right?
我确实有种感觉我快到结尾了，但我实际上不知道。明白了，酷。嗯，我的节目工具是一个叫 `sqlite-dict` 的 Python 库，这是一个奇怪的名字。它是基于 Python 中的字典对象，所以每个做 Python 的人都想过这个问题，你有 Python，你知道，一切都是字典。类是字典。所有的对象都是字典。数据类是字典。所以字典是一个非常基础的对象，对吧？
It's equivalent to like object in JavaScript, right? And so you're constantly passing these around you're setting keys you're sorting them etc etc um and then you always ask yourself well i have this dictionary and maybe it takes like three hours to compute all the keys for this dictionary and and when i'm done i want it like right? Now, if it's the kind of thing where it's a batch job, like you process this dictionary, and then now you just need it on disk, you can turn any dictionary into a JSON object,
它相当于 JavaScript 中的对象，对吧？所以你不断地传递这些东西，设置键，对它们进行排序等等。然后你总是问自己，好吧，我有这个字典，也许计算这个字典的所有键需要三个小时，当我完成时，我想要它……对吧？现在，如果这是一个批处理作业，比如你处理这个字典，然后现在你只需要把它存到磁盘上，你可以把任何字典变成一个 JSON 对象，
a JSON string, and then write that string to disk. Pretty easy. And there's a similar function for going the other direction. There's a library called Pickle where you can pickle any Python object to disk and then unpickle it later. That's great. The challenge becomes
一个 JSON 字符串，然后把那个字符串写到磁盘上。很容易。反方向也有类似的功能。有一个叫 `Pickle` 的库，你可以把任何 Python 对象序列化（pickle）到磁盘，然后再反序列化（unpickle）。那很好。挑战在于
what happens when you need a backup of a dictionary on disk but it's like incremental. It's not practical. Anytime this dictionary changes, you'd have to save the whole thing to disk, right? So what you really need is you start getting into the realm
当你需要磁盘上的字典备份，但它是增量的时候会发生什么？这不切实际。每当这个字典改变时，你都得把整个东西存到磁盘上，对吧？所以你真正需要的是开始进入
of needing a database, right? At some point, you want to use Redis for this or something, right? But that's pretty heavyweight. You need to stand up a database, it needs to live on a port, use TCP to connect to it. It's just like a lot of work, right? You could do it with Docker and stuff to it it's just like a lot of work right you know you could do it with docker and stuff but it's time consuming so ideally you'd have just like a file
需要数据库的领域，对吧？在某些时候，你想为此使用 Redis 之类的，对吧？但那太重了。你需要建立一个数据库，它需要在一个端口上运行，使用 TCP 连接到它。这简直是太麻烦了，对吧？你可以用 Docker 之类的来做，但这很耗时。所以理想情况下，你只需要一个文件
on your computer that has the dictionary on it and you could just access that file the same way you access a regular python dictionary like even it would be even better if like you didn't have to change your code you could just or change a lot of your code you could just replace like if i have a dictionary and i'm stuffing a bunch of data into it i could just replace that dictionary object with some other object and get a dictionary that's persisted on disk right and so there's something built into Python called Shelve, which does this. But Shelve sucks. So there's a bunch of reasons why Shelve is terrible.
在你的电脑上，上面有字典，你可以像访问普通 Python 字典一样访问那个文件。甚至更好的是，如果你不需要改变你的代码，或者不需要改变很多代码，你只需要……如果我有一个字典，我正在往里面塞一堆数据，我可以直接用另一个对象替换那个字典对象，并得到一个持久化在磁盘上的字典，对吧？所以 Python 中内置了一个叫 `Shelve` 的东西，它就是做这个的。但 `Shelve` 很烂。所以 `Shelve` 很糟糕的原因有很多。
The biggest reason is if you're on Mac or Windows, actually it might just be Windows now, but there's definitely a time where if you're on Mac or Windows, you got one database format called dumb. It's literally called dumb. And if you're on Linux, you get this other database format called DBM. So you can be on Linux using Shelve, having a great time. Things are super fast.
最大的原因是如果你在 Mac 或 Windows 上，实际上现在可能只是 Windows，但肯定有一段时间，如果你在 Mac 或 Windows 上，你得到一种叫 `dumb` 的数据库格式。它真的叫 `dumb`。如果你在 Linux 上，你会得到另一种叫 `DBM` 的数据库格式。所以你可以在 Linux 上使用 `Shelve`，玩得很开心。事情超级快。
You run the same code on Mac or Windows, and it's like 300 times slower. And then you're like, well, what happened here? If you could take the time to like dive into it, you find out, oh, it's because instead of using DBM, I'm using dumb, right? So shelf is a mess, right? There's also data corruption. So it's not that often, but sometimes if you use shelf,
你在 Mac 或 Windows 上运行相同的代码，它慢了 300 倍。然后你会想，好吧，这里发生了什么？如果你花时间深入研究，你会发现，哦，这是因为我没有使用 `DBM`，我使用的是 `dumb`，对吧？所以 `Shelve` 是一团糟，对吧？还有数据损坏。所以这种情况不常发生，但有时如果你使用 `Shelve`，
when you go to open or when you go to access a key, you'll get this error. And I don't remember what it is off the top of my head, but effectively the database is corrupt and your data is gone, right? So not a big fan of shelf. Now, SQLite is amazing. SQLite is freaking awesome.
当你去打开或访问一个键时，你会得到这个错误。我记不清具体是什么了，但实际上数据库损坏了，你的数据没了，对吧？所以我不喜欢 `Shelve`。现在，SQLite 很棒。SQLite 太棒了。
Everyone uses it. Your iPhone probably has like 30 SQLite databases running on it um uh you know that's at the os level everyone's using sqlite so sqlite dict basically gives you the api of shelf but under the hood is sqlite and uh you know it's not not going to be... It's one of these things where, like, it's probably a little slower than Shelve. Maybe it's even faster than Shelve. I don't know.
每个人都在用它。你的 iPhone 上可能运行着 30 个 SQLite 数据库……嗯，那是在操作系统层面，每个人都在使用 SQLite。所以 `sqlite-dict` 基本上给了你 `Shelve` 的 API，但在底层是 SQLite。而且，你知道，它不会……它是那种东西，它可能比 `Shelve` 稍微慢一点。也许它甚至比 `Shelve` 快。我不知道。
Probably a little slower than Shelve on Unix. But on Mac and Windows, it's the same speed as the Unix Shelve. So you don't have to worry about that. You can access the database with SQLite in another language or stuff. It's going to be whatever you put in. If you're pickling things and putting them in, then you're going to get just random binary garbage. But if you put in, let's say, a number
在 Unix 上可能比 `Shelve` 稍微慢一点。但在 Mac 和 Windows 上，它和 Unix 上的 `Shelve` 速度一样。所以你不必担心那个。你可以用 SQLite 在另一种语言中访问数据库。它会是你放进去的任何东西。如果你在序列化东西并放进去，那么你只会得到随机的二进制垃圾。但如果你放进去，比如一个数字
into SQLite dict, then you'll see a number in the database, which means you can access it from other languages and stuff. So it's an awesome library. If you're using Shelve, stop using it, use this thing instead. If you're not using any of these, it's another sort of tool in the toolbox that i go to pretty often yeah i i've heard so many issues with pickle so yeah i i think putting it even if it's tedious to get the stuff back out i guess like having something that's sqlite that other you know programming languages whatever could access other programs like feel feels like a win yeah i mean by default shelve and sqlite will both what they'll do is they'll look at the data type of what you're trying to put into the dictionary and if it's a primitive data type it'll just store it if you try to put like a python class
到 `sqlite-dict` 中，那么你会在数据库中看到一个数字，这意味着你可以从其他语言中访问它。所以这是一个很棒的库。如果你正在使用 `Shelve`，别用了，改用这个。如果你没用过这些，这是我经常使用的工具箱里的另一个工具。是的，我听说过很多关于 `pickle` 的问题，所以是的，我觉得即使把东西取出来很繁琐，但拥有一个 SQLite 格式的东西，其他编程语言或其他程序可以访问，感觉像是一个胜利。是的，我的意思是，默认情况下，`Shelve` 和 `sqlite-dict` 都会做的是，它们会查看你试图放入字典的数据类型，如果是原始数据类型，它就会直接存储。如果你试图放入像 Python 类
into the dictionary both of them will pickle it and i totally agree i think instead of trying to throw python classes into either of these you should like convert to json or something like that pickle is good if you're in a hurry but yeah it's i think there's security issues you really have to trust the person who pickled the object and then also there's weirdness around like if you change the class and all of that. Very cool. Well, guess what time it is? It is project planning and management time. I was going to say, thank the Patreon times, but yes, it is. Oh, thank you, Patreon.
到字典中，它们两个都会序列化它。我完全同意，我认为与其试图把 Python 类扔进这两个东西里，你应该转换成 JSON 之类的。如果你赶时间，`pickle` 很好，但是的，我认为有安全问题，你必须真正信任序列化该对象的人，而且如果改变类之类的，也会有奇怪的问题。太酷了。好吧，猜猜现在是什么时间？是项目规划和管理时间。我本来想说，感谢 Patreon 时间，但是的，确实是。哦，谢谢 Patreon。
That's awesome. All right. Thank you to all our Patreons. But yes, it is actually... Yeah, big shout out. It is actually time to talk about project planning. And then we realized maybe a little bit of management. I'll give the disclosure. This is not advice.
那太棒了。好的。感谢我们所有的 Patreon 支持者。但是的，实际上……是的，大声喊出来。现在确实是谈论项目规划的时间了。然后我们意识到也许还有一点管理。我会给出免责声明。这不是建议。
This is just entertainment. No, I'm just kidding. We are software engineers, both. We are not product managers. We are not project managers. We are not like this is just from a sweet perspective it's a very casual conversation so um trying to give people this sort of vibe i guess this is what the cool kids seem to say the vibe of what what this project
这只是娱乐。不，我开玩笑的。我们俩都是软件工程师。我们不是产品经理。我们不是项目经理。我们不是……这只是从一个轻松的角度出发，这是一次非常随意的谈话，所以嗯，我想给人们传达这种氛围，我想这就是酷孩子们似乎所说的，这个项目氛围的含义。
planning is all about and there are things to think about and the you know stuff to go on and uh yeah we're gonna jump right in to to start motivating the reason why. Although, you know, maybe if you took a second, you'd probably get most of these. But the reason to plan your projects, I guess, is to think about the alternative if you don't have a plan. But no, if you work in a company or on a medium or large size project, anything that's, you know, going to take more than just a couple hours, really having a plan is, is important. And, you know, I think there's a bunch of reasons why, but some of it is that having a explicit process where you kind of go and plan what you're doing allows other people
规划的全部意义所在，有很多事情需要考虑，你知道，还有很多事情要进行，是的，我们要直接开始讨论为什么要这样做。虽然，你知道，也许如果你花点时间思考一下，你可能会明白其中的大部分原因。但我认为规划项目的原因是去思考如果你没有计划会怎样。不，如果你在一家公司工作，或者在一个中大型项目上工作，任何需要花费超过几个小时的事情，真正拥有一个计划是很重要的。而且，你知道，我认为有很多原因，但其中一部分是拥有一个明确的流程，让你去规划你正在做的事情，这允许其他人
to give feedback on the plan, right? Make sure your coworkers are aware, make sure everybody's sort of gathered together, um, and to figure out, Hey, what parts of the plan are going to be risky? You know, is this, are we, is there,
对计划提供反馈，对吧？确保你的同事知情，确保每个人都聚在一起，嗯，找出计划中哪些部分是有风险的。你知道，这是，我们，是否有，
you know, Hey, we're going to do this by this date, but there's a holiday break here. So if everybody goes on holiday break, then, you know, we're not going to get our plan done or we're going to have to try this new technology or this new algorithm.
你知道，嘿，我们要在某个日期之前完成这个，但这里有一个假期。所以如果每个人都去度假了，那么，你知道，我们就无法完成我们的计划，或者我们将不得不尝试这种新技术或这种新算法。
We don't, you know, yet know how to do and making sure that sometimes you have blind spots and that people identify, hey, what are you sort of not counting seriously enough? Yeah, yeah, totally agree. I think another really important part of project planning is headcount planning. And this is something where I've seen this go horribly wrong, even at big companies. I definitely am not going to give any personal stories,
我们还不知道该怎么做，而且要确保有时你会有盲点，人们会指出，嘿，你对什么东西的考虑不够认真？是的，完全同意。我认为项目规划中另一个非常重要的部分是人力规划。这是我见过在大型公司里也会出现严重错误的事情。我绝对不会讲任何个人故事，
although I'm thinking a bunch in my head. But I've seen situations where people who asked for, managers who asked for more headcount just got it, just for asking. And it's like, if you didn't ask, you didn't get it. Or I've seen cases where um it was pretty subjective it's like oh your project is kind of cool let's like put more people on it right but but ultimately like the principled objective way to do this is you should plan like what is the expected amount of work that our team is going to accomplish and when you see team
虽然我脑子里想到了很多。但我见过这样的情况，那些要求更多人力的经理，仅仅因为开口要就得到了。就像，如果你不问，你就得不到。或者我见过一些情况，嗯，这相当主观，就像“哦，你的项目挺酷的，让我们多放点人进去吧”，但最终，原则性的、客观的做法是，你应该规划你的团队预计要完成的工作量，当你看到团队
this could be thousands of people it could be four people that still works um and then come up with like a distribution um and maybe like you know this is like science brain of me but come up with like a distribution where you know if you're like one sigma below the distribution, then like that was slightly below expectations. You know, if I'm one sigma above the distribution, that's above expectations. And then that's really important for so many reasons. One is at the end of the year, you need to figure out, did my team perform at my expectations or not? And you can't do that if you don't set expectations. Right. at my expectations or not. And you can't do that if you don't set expectations, right?
这可能是成千上万的人，也可能是四个人，这仍然有效，然后得出一个分布，也许，你知道，这是我科学大脑的思考，得出一个分布，你知道，如果你比分布低一个标准差，那么这稍微低于预期。你知道，如果我比分布高一个标准差，那就是高于预期。这在很多方面都非常重要。第一，在年底，你需要弄清楚，我的团队表现是否达到了我的预期？如果你不设定预期，你就无法做到这一点。对吧。达到了我的预期吗？如果你不设定预期，你就无法做到这一点，对吧？
But the second thing is, you get to see what you didn't do. At the end of the day, adding more people allows you to do things you couldn't do. And you have to know what that is before you can make a case for more people. So at the end of the year, we could say, here's a list of ideas we had. Look, this idea, we didn't do it and someone else did it and they published a paper and that paper was amazing. So that's a miss. Or we had a list of ideas, we didn't get to any of them, but it turns out they were all kind of like maybe not that good.
但第二件事是，你可以看到你没做的事情。归根结底，增加更多的人手可以让你做以前做不到的事情。在你为增加人手提出理由之前，你必须知道那是什么。所以在年底，我们可以说，这是我们有的想法列表。看，这个想法，我们没做，别人做了，他们发表了一篇论文，那篇论文很棒。所以这是一个错失。或者我们有一系列想法，我们一个都没实现，但结果发现它们可能都不太好。
It was all below the fold. And we're actually not really missing out on not hiring people. So I think headcount planning dovetails nicely into this. Thinking about expanding from headcount, not just new hires or you know allocation of people but also making sure if there's other teams upstream or downstream of your work and that there's a dependency either like hey we are going to use this thing that isn't being used today or we're going to assume this thing another team is creating is is going to be available is very important to
它们都不太重要。我们实际上并没有因为没雇人而错过什么。所以我认为人力规划与此衔接得很好。从人力扩展开来思考，不仅仅是新员工或你知道的人员分配，还要确保是否有其他团队在你的工作上游或下游，并且存在依赖关系，比如“嘿，我们将使用这个今天还没被使用的东西”，或者“我们假设另一个团队正在创建的东西将会可用”，这对于
communicate so much i mean it's so obvious but and just in life how many things could be solved by just you know communication and so making sure that you communicate expectations around headcount expectations around we're going to talk about schedule um but also you know thinking through what are the dependencies between modules um and sort of of the APIs that I want to call or depend on downstream, upstream. If you are going to use a third party service pricing, right? Like, am I going to be sensitive to if the prices go up on on these function calls down for me or API calls? You know, is that going to be a problem and sort of making sure you have that. And then when we start to talk about schedule and thinking about, you know, depending on stuff that that's not yet available, or how much it's going to take for you to get your sort of modules or work, you know, implemented work items
沟通来说非常重要，我的意思是这太显而易见了，但在生活中，有多少事情仅仅通过沟通就能解决？所以要确保你沟通关于人力的预期，关于我们将要讨论的时间表的预期，但也要思考模块之间的依赖关系，以及我想要调用或依赖的下游、上游的API。如果你要使用第三方服务定价，对吧？比如，如果这些函数调用或API调用的价格上涨，我会敏感吗？你知道，这会是个问题吗？确保你考虑到这一点。然后当我们开始讨论时间表并思考，你知道，依赖于尚未可用的东西，或者你需要多少时间来实现你的模块或工作项，
implemented, there's also identifying the sort of critical path, what both from terms of the data flow, but also in terms of from your schedule standpoint, what is the sort of thing that if you walk through the schedule, that is, these are the items and some items are happening in parallel, but these are items we expect to take longest. And if we sort of line them all up, this is the sort of length and it's the set of things that are, we are most sensitive to in the final schedule, right? These are the set of things where if we get behind or we aren't able to in the final schedule, right? These are the set of things where if we get behind or we aren't able to handle the risks or, you know, something slips, then our, you know, total schedule slip. And that's very important to, and maybe everything is, is on that path.
实现它们，还有识别所谓的关键路径，无论是从数据流的角度，还是从你的时间表角度，如果走一遍时间表，这些是项目，有些项目是并行发生的，但这些是我们预计花费时间最长的项目。如果我们把它们排成一行，这就是长度，这是我们在最终时间表中对它们最敏感的一组事情，对吧？这些是一组如果我们落后或者我们无法处理风险，或者，你知道，某些东西滑坡了，那么我们的，你知道，总时间表就会滑坡的事情。这非常重要，也许一切都在那条路径上。
That's entirely possible. But if there are things off of that path, I would argue actually knowing that they're off of the path is as important as knowing what's on the path, because when it's off the path, you have a little bit more flexibility, you have a little bit more sort of dynamicism, you know, that Jason was mentioning, thinking about things as a distribution, if you start to get involved, and you find out you're needing more resources from, you know, then you the sort of median was then, you know, you, you can kind of pull them from things that were less important, maybe, right. And if you sort of, you know, kind you, the sort of median was, then, you know, you, you can kind of pull them from things that were less important maybe. Right. And if you sort of, you know, kind of understand which things have which party, there's that classic, I guess, kind of joke. Everything is the most
这完全有可能。但如果有些事情不在那条路径上，我实际上认为知道它们不在路径上和知道什么在路径上一样重要，因为当它不在路径上时，你有更多的灵活性，你有更多的动态性，你知道，Jason提到的，把事情看作一个分布，如果你开始参与其中，发现你需要更多的资源，比中位数多，那么，你知道，你可以从那些不太重要的事情中抽调一些人，也许，对吧。如果你，你知道，理解哪些事情有哪个优先级，有一个经典的，我想，笑话。每件事都是最
important, but if everything's the most important, nothing's important. Um, and every company seems to fail at this, but this is fine. It's just like a difficult thing, but you can't say everything is equally important because you really do need to know if something's going to slip where's it going to come from where are we going to pull things and having that thought through and communicated is is very vital yeah yeah totally one thing that i you know if i could impart any wisdom at all it would be i always underestimate the ripple effects from decisions that I make in the workplace and maybe just universally I think it's just really hard to to measure multi-order effects because usually what you're trying to do is you're you have your own plan like I want to try and
重要的，但如果每件事都是最重要的，那就什么都不重要了。嗯，每家公司似乎都在这一点上失败，但这没关系。这只是一件困难的事情，但你不能说每件事都同样重要，因为你确实需要知道如果某件事要延期，它会从哪里延期，我们要从哪里抽调资源，把这些想清楚并沟通出来是非常至关重要的。是的，完全同意。有一件事，你知道，如果我能传授任何智慧的话，那就是我总是低估我在工作场所做出的决定的连锁反应，也许普遍来说，我认为衡量多阶效应真的很难，因为通常你试图做的是，你有你自己的计划，比如我想尝试并
build this and then I want to try and write this paper and then that paper is like a stepping stone to this other project and then I have this idea maybe it works maybe it doesn't work and so you're like you're doing what deep seek is doing right and it's hard to do that and think about like all the ripple effects of like okay if we're late on this project that causes other team to do this which causes other team to do that um Or even like an even better example is like, given that we're late on this project, if you communicated that now versus next week, that actually can result in totally different outcomes. Even though it was the same, you know, the same effect, the same initial effect could have two totally different outcomes,
构建这个，然后我想尝试写这篇论文，然后那篇论文就像是通往另一个项目的垫脚石，然后我有这个想法，也许它行得通，也许行不通，所以你就像是在做DeepSeek正在做的事情，要做到这一点并思考所有的连锁反应很难，比如“好吧，如果我们在这个项目上迟到了，这会导致其他团队做这个，这会导致其他团队做那个”。或者甚至是一个更好的例子，比如，鉴于我们在项目上迟到了，如果你现在沟通而不是下周沟通，那实际上会导致完全不同的结果。即使是同样的，你知道，同样的效果，同样的初始效果可能会有两个完全不同的结果，
depending on when it was communicated. And these are really difficult things to measure. Yeah, I think the interconnectivity, we can talk about the mythical man month, we can talk about the classic, you know, hey, if I just give you another person, can you go twice as fast? But I mean, a lot of that comes down to what you're saying is like, it is very difficult for human software engineers to understand just how much impact one decision, one choice, one slip, one whatever can have and the sort of compounding you get from that. like a bullwhip effect where you know especially if you're at like the if you're doing research you're kind of like at the beginning of the bullwhip and so if you kind of um make a bad
取决于什么时候沟通。这些是非常难衡量的事情。是的，我认为互联性，我们可以谈论《人月神话》，我们可以谈论经典的，你知道，嘿，如果我再给你一个人，你能快两倍吗？但我的意思是，很多归结为你所说的，人类软件工程师很难理解一个决定、一个选择、一次延期、任何事情能产生多大的影响，以及你从中得到的复合效应。就像鞭梢效应，你知道，特别是如果你在，如果你在做研究，你有点像在鞭梢的开头，所以如果你，嗯，做出一个糟糕的
decision or you don't try to advance something or whatever then that causes like this massive swings downstream so that's actually great uh use of of that term can can you maybe or again but can you kind of explain what the bullwhip effect is? Yeah, so I believe this came out of like supply chain management, but the idea is, you know, let's say you end up with slightly less grain this season. Well, then people will start,
决定，或者你不尝试推进某件事，或者其他什么，那么这会导致下游巨大的波动，所以这实际上是一个很好的术语用法，你能，或者再次，你能解释一下什么是鞭梢效应吗？是的，我相信这来自供应链管理，但这个想法是，你知道，假设你这个季节的谷物稍微少了一点。那么，人们就会开始，
you know, people downstream of that will start to experience shortages and they'll start to you know buy up volume and do different things to like handle those shortages and so then some of those processes that they start implementing like buying extra surplus doing all these extra things they'll continue next year even when you don't have a shortage so they're kind of like because they're downstream of you they're reacting to you and their reactions are very quick and so they end up like buying more than they need and the next year you have a surplus and they're still buying more than they
你知道，下游的人们会开始经历短缺，他们会开始，你知道，抢购库存并做不同的事情来处理这些短缺，所以他们开始实施的一些流程，比如购买额外的剩余物资，做所有这些额外的事情，即使在你没有短缺的时候，他们明年也会继续这样做，所以他们有点像，因为他们在你的下游，他们在对你做出反应，他们的反应非常快，所以他们最终买的比他们需要的更多，第二年你有了剩余，而他们还在买比他们
need and so now they have to like double correct um maybe you know yeah and so and so so it has this compounding effect right and that's just one step so imagine if there's a supply chain of like 20 steps the person 20 steps down just experiencing like wild volatility because of all of these kind of like mispredictions did i get that right yeah yeah yeah so if you think about like software that is finally delivered or a product that ends up on a shelf on a store and you think about all the unique steps that it takes to get there and especially when they're sort of like a continuous continuous process which we could kind of talk about software being viewed as a sort of one shot or continuous but yeah it's just sort of like as you add these dependency things small
需要的更多，所以现在他们不得不进行双重修正，也许，你知道，是的，所以它有这种复合效应，对吧？那只是一步，所以想象一下如果有一个20步的供应链，第20步的人只是因为所有这些错误的预测而经历着疯狂的波动，我理解对了吗？是的，是的，所以如果你考虑最终交付的软件，或者最终出现在商店货架上的产品，你考虑到达那里所需的所有独特步骤，特别是当它们是一种连续的过程时，我们可以谈论软件被视为一种一次性或连续的过程，但是的，这就像当你增加这些依赖项时，开始时的小
perturbations in the beginning if you you sort of like, if everybody sort of stacks it up, they just, they get compounding. And so, yeah, I think that can, can definitely be there. And when you talk about, and I think we were going to maybe talk about that, but I think it makes sense now is if everybody sort of tries to, and you were sort of saying like overbuy or have buffer or allocate a little extra, right? And so if you were sort of saying like over buy or have buffer or allocate a little extra right and so if you take all of the teams and all of the steps and everybody sort of buffers up so that you know they're not the ones called out you end up with something that's really like four or five x longer or more expensive than it needs to be because you end up with all this hidden sort of
扰动，如果你，你有点像，如果每个人都堆积起来，它们就会产生复合效应。所以，是的，我认为这绝对可能存在。当你谈论时，我想我们可能要谈论那个，但我认为现在说很有意义，如果每个人都试图，你刚才说的那种过度购买或留有缓冲或多分配一点，对吧？所以如果你说过度购买或留有缓冲或多分配一点，对吧，如果你把所有的团队和所有的步骤都拿出来，每个人都留有缓冲，这样，你知道，他们就不会是被点名批评的人，你最终得到的东西实际上比需要的长四五倍或更昂贵，因为你最终得到了所有这些隐藏的
like padding that occurs all over the place. And so you'll hear that, that like upper management will sometimes say, you know, like I, whatever they tell me, I cut it in half or I cut it in 20%. And this is what they're talking about. And it happens with budgets. It happens with headcount. It happens with schedule where everybody sort of pads and then the people over them pad and then the people over them pad. And you end up with like ridiculous amounts of padding. And so there is this element when you're doing project planning of trust, right, that you need to be actually honest. And there's already difficult enough to even estimate how long somebody is going to take. also playing this game of politicizing it now does that actually happen no i think everybody politicizes it to some extent sure but you know the less of it that you can have the better which is hey you're brutally honest with your manager they're brutally honest with their manager and
填充物，它们到处都是。所以你会听到，高层管理有时会说，你知道，比如我，他们告诉我什么，我就砍掉一半，或者我砍掉20%。这就是他们所说的。这发生在预算上。这发生在人力上。这发生在时间表上，每个人都在填充，然后他们上面的人也在填充，再上面的人也在填充。你最终得到了荒谬数量的填充。所以当你进行项目规划时，有一个信任的要素，对吧，你需要真正诚实。而且仅仅估计某人需要多长时间就已经够难了，现在还要玩这种政治化游戏，这真的会发生吗？不，我认为每个人都在某种程度上政治化了它，当然，但你知道，你能减少这种行为越好，也就是，嘿，你对你的经理极其诚实，他们对他们的经理极其诚实，并且
you have an actual view up and down the chain of what's happening and just like we talked about the bullwhip effect unfortunately it only takes one of those links or one of those layers to be i don't want to say like a bad actor but to just try to make sure like i'm definitely not going to be the one who is called out and and they sort of add something how at the top are you supposed to know you know how honest all of the estimates all of the the work is and so yeah the bullwhip effect can be unintentional but i will say it also works kind of in estimates all of the the work is and so yeah the bullwhip effect can be unintentional but i will say it also works kind of in this sort of like intentional safety that people add sort of aggravates the effect even more yeah yeah totally right i think that you know that's a good point i
你对链条上下发生了什么有一个真实的看法，就像我们谈论的鞭梢效应，不幸的是，只需要那些环节或层级中的一个，我不想说是坏人，但只是试图确保“我绝对不会是被点名批评的那个人”，他们就会添加一些东西。在顶层，你怎么可能知道所有估计、所有工作有多诚实？所以，是的，鞭梢效应可能是无意的，但我会说它在某种程度上也起作用，在人们添加的这种意图性的安全感中，这使得效应更加严重。是的，完全正确，我认为这是一个很好的观点。
mean sort of a meta point here is like you know i notice i see people who transition from an individual contributor to a manager and they start off with like okay how can everything be perfect like how do i make everybody's tasks done what do i have to do to kind of like rewrite history so that like everything we set out to do in march we now have accomplished you know next year and and uh everyone on my team is perfect they all need to get promoted all the time and then over time you start you start like calibrating and you say okay like the goal actually isn't to like play the organization system as if it's monopoly or something right the goal is to like have the most accurate assessment of the situation and um and so so i mean you know the earlier example of like put things on your
我的意思是这里的一个元观点是，你知道，我注意到我看到人们从个人贡献者转变为经理，他们开始时就像“好吧，怎么才能让一切都完美？我怎么才能让每个人的任务都完成？我必须做什么来重写历史，以便我们在三月份设定的所有目标，我们现在在明年都完成了”，你知道，我团队里的每个人都很完美，他们都需要一直被提拔，然后随着时间的推移，你开始校准，你说“好吧，目标实际上不是像玩大富翁那样玩组织系统，对吧？目标是对情况有最准确的评估”。
plan that you feel unlikely that you're going to accomplish um and then when you don't accomplish those that's that's normal like you should you's normal. You should set your team up so that there's an upper and a lower bound that they can achieve. And statistically, you will eventually have a quarter where your team massively underperforms. That's how it's going to work statistically. You're going to draw that short straw you know so many times in your life right and so and so uh i think project planning also helps keep people from panicking it's like you know yeah we missed this quarter but you know we didn't miss the past three quarters and so so this is natural. And so we pick it up next quarter. Yeah, I mean, I think that's a great transition
所以，我的意思是，你知道，早些时候的例子，比如把那些你觉得不太可能完成的事情放在你的计划里，然后当你没有完成那些事情时，那是正常的。你应该设定你的团队，使他们有一个可以达到的上限和下限。从统计学上讲，你最终会有一个季度你的团队表现大幅下滑。从统计学上讲，事情就是这样运作的。你一生中会抽到那根短签很多次，对吧？所以，我认为项目规划也有助于防止人们恐慌，就像“你知道，是的，我们错过了这个季度，但你知道，我们没有错过过去三个季度”，所以这是自然的。所以我们在下个季度补回来。是的，我的意思是，我认为这是一个很好的过渡
to goal setting, but I think it becomes almost a parody, a joke when you see people who set goals and then they always get exactly the goal or like exactly the goal, plus some like little fudge factor. And it's always slightly more, like I always accomplished 1.03 of whatever my metric was
到目标设定，但我认为当你看到人们设定目标，然后他们总是正好达到目标，或者正好达到目标，加上一点点调整因素，这几乎变成了一种模仿，一个笑话。而且总是稍微多一点，比如我总是完成了我指标的1.03
and it's like if you never come under your goal to your point you actually don't have the distribution set correctly like it should be 50 50 sometimes you're over and sometimes you're under and that's life and that's actually means you have the the sort of estimates well set and if you don't you're just sort of like goofing around gaming the system under whatever, you know, like, at least that's, that's sort of my opinion. I mean, maybe you're in some, you know, hockey stick growth thing. And it actually is just really, really difficult to predict that can happen. But setting goals is, is very critical. And I think also being flexible and not saying which we've can sometimes happen. The plan isn't there to say,
就像如果你从来没有低于你的目标，按照你的观点，你实际上没有正确设定分布，它应该是50/50，有时你超额，有时你不足，这就是生活，这实际上意味着你的估计设定得很好，如果你不这样做，你只是在胡闹，在玩弄系统，无论如何，你知道，至少那是我的观点。我的意思是，也许你处于某种曲棍球棒式的增长中。而预测这一点确实非常非常困难，这种情况可能会发生。但设定目标是非常关键的。而且我认为也要灵活，不要说，这有时会发生。计划不是为了说，
oh, we've ruined the beautiful plan, you know, plans never encounter the first, you know, never survived the first encounter with, you know, real life or the enemy or, you know, use whatever your favorite, you know, quote there, I'm butchering, but I think the plan is there to help give people the feeling that like, no, it's okay. We have these things written down. We have them documented. We know what to go adjust, who to go tell, what is going to be impacted, not, oh my gosh, you've ruined all of our work. And I very dislike working in situations where people are like, we made the plan and now the plan is ruined. And it's like, well, then there was probably not a good plan. Like the purpose of the plan is to help us not hurt us but on setting goals you know there's a mnemonic that that you'll hear which is set your goals to be
哦，我们毁了美丽的计划，你知道，计划从来没有在第一次接触现实生活或敌人时幸存下来，或者，你知道，用你最喜欢的任何名言，我可能说错了，但我认为计划的存在是为了帮助人们有一种感觉，即“不，没关系。我们把这些事情写下来了。我们记录下来了。我们知道去调整什么，去告诉谁，什么会受到影响，而不是‘哦天哪，你毁了我们所有的工作’”。我非常不喜欢在人们说“我们制定了计划，现在计划毁了”的情况下工作。我的意思是，那可能就不是一个好的计划。计划的目的是帮助我们，而不是伤害我们。但在设定目标方面，你知道，有一个助记符你会听到，那就是把你的目标设定为
smart yeah totally um my favorite um my favorite my favorite quote is the mike tyson one where he says everyone has a plan until they get punched in the face oh there you go um so smart goals stands for that the the acronym smart is specific measurable achievable relevant and time bound and so if you've ever taken any kind of project management course in any of your work, you'll hear this come up. Yeah, I think it's one of those things where, again, maybe it feels a bit obvious. It's actually really useful if you have set goals and you actually ask yourself personal goals, project plan goals. But, you know, have you done all of these things? I often find that, oh, yeah, despite the fact that when you say it this way, it's pretty obvious. Yeah, I often screw up at least two of them, I think everyone's like, well, when's task X going to be done? But the measurable one,
SMART。是的，完全正确。我最喜欢的名言是迈克·泰森的那句，他说“每个人都有计划，直到他们被一拳打在脸上”。哦，原来如此。所以SMART目标代表那个，SMART这个缩写是具体的（Specific）、可衡量的（Measurable）、可实现的（Achievable）、相关的（Relevant）和有时限的（Time-bound）。所以如果你参加过任何工作中的项目管理课程，你都会听到这个。是的，我认为这是那种，再次，也许感觉有点显而易见的事情。如果你设定了目标，并且你实际上问自己个人目标、项目计划目标，这实际上非常有用。但是，你知道，你做过所有这些事情吗？我经常发现，哦，是的，尽管当你这样说时，它很明显。是的，我经常至少搞砸其中两个，我想每个人都会说“好吧，任务X什么时候完成？”，但可衡量的那个，
that is the one where I often catch people and have to iterate. So someone will say, for example, like build the foo widget, right? And so we all have to agree that just building the foo widget is a good thing you know and that happens sometimes right but generally i'll push back and say okay like well what what is the point of the foo widget you know like here's a company you know kpis here's a company
那是我经常抓住人们并不得不迭代的地方。所以有人会说，例如，“构建Foo小部件”，对吧？所以我们都必须同意，仅仅构建Foo小部件是一件好事，你知道，这有时会发生，对吧？但通常我会反驳说“好吧，Foo小部件的意义是什么？”，你知道，比如这是公司的KPI，这是公司的
you know metrics right um do we need to create a new metric like is this a new dimension that we need to be looking at um and and you know it might be that you know we're going to create the foo thing uh the foo widget um and then we're going to have like a list of things we're going to measure on the foo widget um and so and so then you can like distill down to the goal so so if the if you're creating the foo widget because you have a new sort of segment of customers right what are those customers going to do well they're going to buy the foo widget how much does a foo widget cost it costs twenty dollars okay so so we have a goal that you know we're going to we're going to make like a hundred thousand dollars in the first three months selling this
指标，对吧？我们需要创建一个新指标吗？这是我们需要关注的新维度吗？而且，你知道，可能是我们将会创建Foo东西，Foo小部件，然后我们将有一个我们要在Foo小部件上衡量的东西列表，所以你就可以提炼出目标。所以，如果你创建Foo小部件是因为你有一个新的客户群，对吧？那些客户会做什么？好吧，他们会买Foo小部件。Foo小部件多少钱？它要20美元。好的，所以我们有一个目标，你知道，我们要在前三个月通过销售这个
food that we haven't built yet like like there should be some way to to get it down to a measurable thing where you're not measuring like yeah the thing is built that's that's that's one or the thing is not built that's zero you know like getting a a proper measurement that like connects to the company's objective and and all that i think is is really important um um so you know sometimes you might build things you know you see this a lot in research like you build things that um that are trying to kind of push the industry in a new direction and and even in these cases there should be some way to measure even if it's an internal benchmark or something like that uh maybe instead of building the foo widget what you need to build is the benchmark that you're expecting the foo widget
我们还没构建出来的东西赚到十万美元。应该有一种方法可以把它变成一个可衡量的东西，而不是衡量“是的，东西建好了，那是1，或者东西没建好，那是0”。你知道，得到一个与公司目标相连的正确衡量标准，所有这些，我认为非常重要。所以，你知道，有时你可能会构建东西，你知道，你在研究中经常看到这种情况，你构建的东西试图推动行业向新的方向发展，即使在这些情况下，也应该有一种衡量方法，即使它是内部基准或其他什么。也许与其构建Foo小部件，你需要构建的是你期望Foo小部件
to outperform in and we need to actually build that thing because otherwise someone will build the foo widget they'll be super proud of it and then they're wondering like why their performance review wasn't good you know so it's like well you have to build the thing sometimes you have to build the thing that motivates or or explains the efficacy of the actual thing um and so so the measurable one is super key you know the other ones i feel are you know like specific it's kind of like okay everyone should always be specific achievable it's like how could you have a non-achievable goal but but the measurable and the time bound seem the ones that really stick with me. You've never had your manager set a non-achievable goal?
超越的基准，我们需要实际构建那个东西，否则有人会构建Foo小部件，他们会为此感到非常自豪，然后他们会纳闷为什么他们的绩效评估不好。所以，你知道，你必须构建那个东西，有时你必须构建那个激励或解释实际东西功效的东西。所以可衡量的那个是关键。其他的，我觉得是，你知道，比如具体的，这就像“好吧，每个人都应该总是具体的”。可实现的，这就像“怎么会有不可实现的目标？”，但可衡量的和有时限的似乎是真正让我印象深刻的。你从来没有遇到过你的经理设定一个不可实现的目标吗？
Oh, man. If so, you've been incredibly lucky. So I feel like I have to be diplomatic. I've definitely had managers set non-achievable goals. But not once have I ever said, this goal is unachievable and they've said okay we'll change it so so so it seems almost like uh i do think that achievable goals are more achievable but i don't think that knowing that is going to help you get a impossible goal um and make it achievable like i've seen um so one time they wanted this metric to go up by some ungodly amount and i i basically was saying like you know
哦，天哪。如果是这样，你真是太幸运了。所以我感觉我必须外交一点。我绝对遇到过经理设定不可实现的目标。但从来没有一次我说“这个目标是不可实现的”，然后他们说“好的，我们改一下”。所以这看起来几乎像……我确实认为可实现的目标更容易实现，但我不认为知道这一点会帮助你把一个不可能的目标变成可实现的。我见过……有一次他们想要这个指标增加一个不可思议的量，我基本上是在说“你知道，
it's not it's not really going to happen and what ended up happening was the metric went up by a nominal amount and then everyone was kind of meh about it. So the fact that the goal is unachievable, I don't know if it really changed anything. Well, then I think that's the point of the sort of letters working together. Like if it being unachievable didn't matter, I mean, I think that's because it wasn't a good goal. Like you could have had a better goal that would have helped people rally around it or would have done something slightly different. And maybe it could have been at least 2x of whatever the nominal increase is, maybe not 1000x. Sure. But like, it being more achievable, could have been
这真的不会发生”，结果指标增加了一个名义上的量，然后每个人都对此感到平平。所以目标不可实现的事实，我不知道它是否真的改变了什么。好吧，那我认为这就是那些字母共同作用的意义所在。如果它不可实现并不重要，我的意思是，我认为那是因为它不是一个好的目标。你本可以有一个更好的目标，那会帮助人们团结在它周围，或者会做一些稍微不同的事情。也许它至少可以是名义增长的2倍，也许不是1000倍。当然。但它更可实现，可能
potentially more motivating to people because there could have been a path to it. Yeah, I mean, this is tough, right? So if someone sets a really ambitious goal, that gets people excited. It gets their managers excited. It gets your team really excited. And then if you are directionally accurate and you do make an improvement, but it wasn't the enormous outstanding outstanding improvement it's really tough i mean like your instinct is to say well i expected let's say a two to four x improvement my director promised
对人们更有激励作用，因为可能有一条通往它的路径。是的，我的意思是，这很难，对吧？所以如果有人设定了一个非常有野心的目标，那会让人们兴奋。会让他们的经理兴奋。会让你的团队非常兴奋。然后如果你方向准确并且确实做出了改进，但它不是那种巨大的杰出改进，这真的很难。我的意思是，你的本能是说“好吧，我期望，比如说2到4倍的改进，我的总监承诺了
a 400 x improvement we got a 3x improvement like your instincts is to say like yeah that was like a giant mess up like the the the head honcho should have just predicted a forex improvement but then it's like when i look back on it it's like that that like fake number caused so much excitement it's like it's kind of like a counter to it if they get actually worked out um i don't know this gets really complicated, but I guess if it's measurable, then maybe that just makes it at least somewhat really solid. I think people can often, and as we're kind of saying here, I think people can take things for unintended reasons or take them too far. But one of the things is Gantt charts. So if you sort of represent each of the tasks as a sort of, I guess, like a rectangle, a
400倍的改进，我们得到了3倍的改进”，你的本能是说“是的，那是一个巨大的搞砸，头头本应该预测4倍的改进”。但后来当我回顾它时，就像那个虚假的数字引起了太多的兴奋，这就像是对它的一个反击，如果它们真的成功了……我不知道，这变得非常复杂，但我猜如果它是可衡量的，那么也许这至少让它在某种程度上非常扎实。我认为人们经常，正如我们在这里所说的，我认为人们可以因为意想不到的原因而采取行动，或者做得太过分。但其中一件事是甘特图。所以如果你把每个任务表示为一种，我猜，矩形，一个
bubble, and you sort of schedule them over time and you sort of draw interdependencies, it kind of sounds stupid, but you often will discover like we have work scheduled to begin before the thing that it is needing at input finishes right oh well that that is not going to work and if you just sort of say hey you know to do b we need a a is going to finish in q1 we're going to start b in you know february it's like well wait a minute like A is going to finish in Q1. We're going to start B in, you know, February. It's like, well, wait a minute. Like, are you going to be able to do work? And then you would say, well, you know, we can start it. Well, then it's really probably two tasks, like getting ready and then executing, right? And so it helps you to decompose them, which again, then helps with what we talked
气泡，你把它们安排在时间轴上，你画出相互依赖关系，这听起来有点蠢，但你经常会发现，我们安排的工作在它需要的输入完成之前就开始了。哦，好吧，那行不通。如果你只是说“嘿，你知道，要做B，我们需要A，A将在第一季度完成，我们将在二月开始B”，这就像“等一下，A将在第一季度完成。我们将在二月开始B。这就像，等一下。你能够工作吗？”然后你会说“好吧，你知道，我们可以开始它”。好吧，那它实际上可能是两个任务，比如准备和执行，对吧？所以它帮助你分解它们，这反过来又帮助我们谈论
about earlier, you know, headcount, slack buffering, understanding what's critical and not critical. And so putting up a Gantt chart is a way to sort of say, and in some ways, you know, not the right use, but work backwards and say, hey, we really need this to be done by this date, if we really put all the processes in place and say, you know, when do we think we need them? And sometimes you realize, oh, actually, we need to start this a lot sooner than we thought. And then you say, oh, we don't have the right personnel. And that's always a very delicate thing to balance, which is, hey, you may need 10 people in the beginning and only two people at the end. Is there a way for us to be thoughtful and make it so that we have a more level head
早些时候提到的，你知道，人力、松弛缓冲、理解什么是关键的，什么不是关键的。所以放上一个甘特图是一种方式，去说，在某些方面，你知道，不是正确的使用方式，但倒推并说“嘿，我们真的需要这个在某个日期前完成，如果我们真的把所有的流程都落实到位，并说，你知道，我们认为什么时候需要它们？”有时你会意识到“哦，实际上，我们需要比我们想象的早得多开始这个”。然后你说“哦，我们没有合适的人员”。这总是一个非常微妙的平衡，也就是，嘿，你可能开始时需要10个人，最后只需要两个人。有没有一种方法让我们深思熟虑，使我们有一个更平稳的人力
count throughout? Because it's very difficult to need 10 people and then just get rid of them. Ramping up is generally easy. Ramping down can be a bit more difficult. And so is there tasks that aren't in this dependency chain that we can reschedule or reallocate and sort of make it a little bit more palatable?
贯穿始终？因为需要10个人然后解雇他们是非常困难的。增加人手通常很容易。减少人手可能更困难。所以有没有不在这个依赖链中的任务，我们可以重新安排或重新分配，并使它稍微更容易接受？
And so Gantt charts are a very specific way of sort of identifying the interconnectivity between the tasks and the schedule. Yep. Yep. That makes sense. A couple of like, you'll hear these methodologies get thrown around like Scrum, Agile, Waterfall. And I have to confess, like, they all occupy some like really nebulous part of my brain
所以甘特图是一种非常具体的方式，用来识别任务和时间表之间的互联性。是的。是的，这说得通。你会听到这些方法论被抛出来，比如Scrum、敏捷、瀑布。我必须承认，它们都占据了我大脑中一些非常模糊的部分，
where it all just kind of flows together like one of these really weird text-to-image things. If you put in a theory of mind into a text-to-image generator, you just get garbage. So I don't quite understand the different nuances and differences there. I'll just say my piece on it. And then Patrick, you probably have a lot more experience. I generally feel like you should just consistently be replanning. So in my case, like right now, for example, I have a weekly planning
它们就像这些非常奇怪的文本转图像的东西一样融合在一起。如果你把心智理论放入文本转图像生成器中，你只会得到垃圾。所以我不太理解其中的细微差别和差异。我只会说我的看法。然后Patrick，你可能有更多的经验。我通常觉得你应该持续地重新规划。所以在我的情况下，比如现在，我有每周的规划
meeting at my current job. And so we look at the last week's plan and the quarterly plan and how are things trending. And I just think it's really important to stay kind of on top of your plan and just discuss it every week. And then also have like a very quick touch base every day of like,
会议。所以我们查看上周的计划和季度计划，事情的趋势如何。我只是认为保持在计划之上并每周讨论它真的很重要。然后还要有，比如每天非常快速的碰头，比如，
hey, how are things going? What's the roadblocks? What are the barriers? What are the accomplishments? And just kind of touch base. And beyond that, I haven't really found any of these, like, acronyms or any of these words
嘿，事情进展如何？障碍是什么？障碍是什么？成就是什么？只是碰个头。除此之外，我还没有发现任何这些，比如缩写或任何这些词
like Scrum or Agile to be particularly useful. I think it's one of those, like, people are surprised when I talk about it. In general, it has been my experience in talking to a lot of other people that I work with and around that the sort of Silicon Valley tech companies are a bit unique in a couple of ways where they try to hire people that are very talented. They try to hire people who aren't hyper specialized by default. They generally prefer people who are flexible more than specialized. And their customers are like end shipping products and not, you know, pay for, you know, accomplishments and milestones.
比如Scrum或敏捷特别有用。我认为这是那种，人们在谈论它时感到惊讶的事情。总的来说，根据我与我一起工作和周围的许多其他人交谈的经验，硅谷科技公司在几个方面有点独特，他们试图雇佣非常有才华的人。他们试图雇佣那些默认情况下不是超级专业化的人。他们通常更喜欢灵活的人而不是专业化的人。他们的客户是最终交付产品的，而不是，你知道，为成就和里程碑付费。
So you'll hear about even internally, we'll talk about like setting milestones. If you worked where you were contracting for another company to deliver something and they weren't going to pay you all the money up front without knowing that it was done and you need to pay your engineers. So you can't take all the money at the end when you finished. So you need milestones. Those milestones need to be evaluated. I think you get a lot more process heavy, you know culture which is completely makes sense silicon
所以你会听到即使在内部，我们也会谈论设定里程碑。如果你工作的地方是你为另一家公司承包交付某样东西，而他们不会在不知道它完成的情况下预付所有钱，而你需要支付你的工程师工资。所以你不能在最后完成时拿走所有的钱。所以你需要里程碑。那些里程碑需要被评估。我认为你会变得更加流程繁重，你知道，文化，这完全说得通。硅
valley is a little different and that people can kind of tackle many many of the different tasks that are within a project that may be better or worse but they try to be generally less specialized than than maybe in other uh industries and the fact that most of the stuff is all what is internally funded they're not doing it against a contract they're just internally trying to do research and try to make the product better and ship metrics so all the goal setting is internally motivated rather than tied to dollar amounts that occur for incremental progress it's sort of the end outcomes that matter and nothing along the way it's just sort of like get it done leads to a more uh flexible dynamic less strict stricture around sort of following this methodology but if
谷有点不同，人们可以处理项目中的许多不同任务，这可能更好或更糟，但他们试图比其他行业的人更不专业化。而且事实上，大部分东西都是内部资助的，他们不是根据合同做的，他们只是在内部尝试做研究，尝试让产品更好并交付指标，所以所有的目标设定都是内部驱动的，而不是与为增量进展而发生的美元金额挂钩。重要的是最终结果，而不是过程中的任何东西，这只是像“把它做完”，这导致了一种更灵活、动态、围绕遵循这种方法论的限制更少的环境，但如果
you look at like defense contractors or people doing contract software for other companies you end up with a lot more of these and there are good ways of doing them in bad ways and pros and cons of each of them but in the end a lot of it is dictated by how the money is going to flow from the person paying for the work to the people doing the work. And so I also have very little experience. I can't talk about pros and cons of various ways of doing these things because in general, I would say, like Jason is sort of saying, it's a sort of continuous process where we're doing this but it's not very formalized it's a very informal process and you rely heavily on everyone generally
如果你看看国防承包商或为其他公司做合同软件的人，你会发现这类情况很多。处理这些问题有好的方法，也有坏的方法，每种方法都有其优缺点，但归根结底，很大程度上取决于资金如何从付款方流向工作执行方。所以我的经验也很少。我无法谈论各种处理方式的优缺点，因为总的来说，就像杰森所说的那样，这是一个持续的过程，我们一直在做，但并没有非常正式化，这是一个非常非正式的过程，你很大程度上依赖于每个人通常
being aligned towards the same goal and acutely we'll see when people on the team aren't aligned to the same goal it's actually problematic that there's none of these processes in place when everyone is aligned and has the right incentives it's actually amazing because you don't end up with any of the overhead that these processes uh would have and so it's sort of a i don't pick your poison kind of thing i'm not saying it's better i'm not saying it's worse it's just very different yeah that makes sense and and um i guess okay maybe we could distill the few sort of like key components to all of these methods. Generally, you know, when you're doing any type of project planning, you have a backlog.
都朝着同一个目标努力。我们确实会看到，当团队成员目标不一致时，没有这些流程确实会产生问题。而当每个人都目标一致且激励机制正确时，这其实非常棒，因为你不会有这些流程带来的任何额外开销。所以这有点像“两害相权取其轻”，我不是说它更好，也不是说它更差，只是非常不同。是的，这很有道理。我想，也许我们可以提炼出所有这些方法中的几个关键组成部分。通常，当你进行任何类型的项目规划时，你都会有一个待办事项列表。
So the backlog are your ideas that you've thought up, but you're not ready to work on. Typically, you'll get a lot of tasks assigned to you from other teams or other members of your team and and then you have your you know current things that you're working on and and the gantt chart that patrick mentioned and all of that associated with that and then you have things that are you've basically committed to like these are things that we're definitely going to do and maybe you even have dates on those but they're not in progress um and so effectively what you're doing on a weekly basis is you're you're looking at your backlog you're saying like are there things that we should add to this backlog like have people thought of new things there's derivative work is there a task that needs to be split and that
所以待办事项列表就是你想到但还没准备好去做的想法。通常，你会从其他团队或团队成员那里分配到很多任务，然后你有你目前正在做的事情，以及帕特里克提到的甘特图和所有相关内容，还有你基本上已经承诺要做的事情，比如这些是我们肯定会做的，也许你甚至给它们定了日期，但它们还没有开始进行。所以实际上你每周都在做的事情就是查看你的待办事项列表，看看是否应该添加一些内容，比如人们是否想到了新东西，是否有衍生工作，是否有任务需要拆分，而那个
second part needs to go in the backlog um and then you're also assigning sort of like a rough amount of work to the things that are in the backlog like is this a a really large task a tiny task and then what's the priority so you're trying to prioritize that backlog even before you start pulling things up um and then you're depending on the job you have worked different jobs where the sometimes like like in research things are really staggered right because you have all these different conferences and they all have different deadlines so like so the person who wants to submit to icml they're on a totally different schedule than a person who wants to submit to ICML, they're on a totally different schedule than a person who wants to submit to NeurIPS because those conferences have different deadlines. If you're not dealing with that kind of world, then you can maybe have something more regular where at the end of the quarter, the entire team does a retrospective of the whole quarter you know that's something that can work if you're in a less heterogeneous environment um but i think you know
第二部分需要进入待办事项列表。然后你还要为待办事项列表中的任务分配大致的工作量，比如这是一个非常大的任务还是一个微小的任务，然后优先级是什么。所以你甚至在开始处理之前就试图对那个待办事项列表进行优先级排序。然后根据工作的不同，你做过不同的工作，有时像在研究领域，事情是非常错开的，因为你有各种不同的会议，它们都有不同的截止日期。所以想向ICML投稿的人，他们的时间表与想向NeurIPS投稿的人完全不同，因为这些会议的截止日期不同。如果你不是在处理那种环境，那么你也许可以有更规律的安排，在季度末，整个团队对整个季度进行回顾。如果你处于一个不那么异构的环境中，这确实可行，但我认为你知道
so the two big pieces of advice for project planning and this is important whether you are a project manager an individual contributor a manager etc um you know is look backwards just as often as you look forward so you can kind of calibrate yourself you know, look backwards just as often as you look forward. So you can kind of calibrate yourself, you know, have a weekly meeting where you kind of go through those different states of your tasks. And then also make sure that you're putting new ideas down. I've seen a trap where people will just get into bug fixing mode and kind of forget to innovate. And so sometimes you have to put a bug on hold so you can innovate. And again, if people are upset about that, that's when you go back and say,
所以项目规划的两大建议，无论你是项目经理、个人贡献者还是经理等，这都很重要。那就是：回顾过去和展望未来一样频繁，这样你才能校准自己。你知道，回顾过去和展望未来一样频繁，这样你才能校准自己。每周开一次会，过一遍任务的不同状态。同时确保你记下了新的想法。我见过一个陷阱，人们只会进入修复漏洞的模式，而忘记了创新。所以有时你必须暂停修复漏洞，以便进行创新。同样，如果人们对此感到不满，那就是你回去说的时候，
well, this gets back to headcount planning, right? But I've seen it a lot in research where you know research idea becomes production server and then all of a sudden like it becomes total project planning chaos um and uh and these are all steps that will help mitigate that um quickly just cover some of the the tools that you might hear that are associated with this. My favorite is whiteboard. And then I had to clarify because it sounded like it was a product name, but just like an actual whiteboard and people in a room standing around and quickly like it, you know,
嗯，这又回到了人员规划的问题上，对吧？但我经常在研究领域看到这种情况，你知道，研究想法变成了生产服务器，然后突然之间，项目规划就变得一团糟。这些步骤都有助于缓解这种情况。快速介绍一下你可能听到的与此相关的工具。我最喜欢的是白板。然后我不得不澄清一下，因为它听起来像是一个产品名称，但其实就是一块真正的白板，人们在房间里站在一起，快速地，你知道，
and I'm we talked about work from home from last time. But I will say one of the things that most I think can be difficult without just being there and like on a piece of paper or on a whiteboard is just that real iterative dynamicism that happens very early in the process specifically, or, you know, when you're really under a lot of change, the digital tools, for me, at least are just, they're not as easy to kind of just like put up something, draw it, redraw the arrow, move it here, move it there. You know, you're trying to the tool forces a certain behavior, versus to kind of just like put up something draw it redraw the arrow move it here move it there you know you're trying to the tool forces a certain behavior versus you kind of just want it to be at least for stuff i do a little more free free flowing in that early project planning stage if only someone made a really really large ink tablet like four by six feet like the size of a whiteboard but it's e-ink yeah this is all i
我们上次谈到了居家办公。但我不得不说，我认为如果没有身临其境，或者没有纸笔或白板，最困难的事情之一就是那种在流程早期发生的真正的迭代动态性。或者，当你处于巨大的变化中时，对我来说，数字工具至少不像那样容易，比如写下一些东西，画出来，重画箭头，移到这里，移到那里。你知道，你试图让工具强制执行某种行为，而你只是想让它，至少对于我做的事情来说，在项目规划的早期阶段更自由流动。要是有人能制造出一块非常非常大的电子墨水平板就好了，比如4乘6英尺，像白板那么大，但它是电子墨水的。是的，这就是我
want please some some factory and and what you need is like modular e-ink panels like with magnets on the side you can just like build your own put a bezel on it stitch them together whatever that would be amazing um yeah whiteboarding really important uh really useful do you how do you use a whiteboard since you're remote patrick yeah i don't have a good answer for it occasional like on-site visits is is a good is a good way um to try to accomplish that and planning when done right i mean doesn't that kind of stuff doesn't need to be done super super frequently i mean updates to a plan sure but um you know that that sort of initial stuff doesn't happen quite as often um but i mean there are you know you know digital whiteboards that you can erase and draw
想要的，拜托哪家工厂做一下。你需要的是像模块化的电子墨水面板，侧面有磁铁，你可以自己组装，加上边框，把它们缝合在一起，那将是太棒了。是的，白板非常重要，非常有用。帕特里克，既然你是远程办公，你是怎么使用白板的？是的，我没有很好的答案。偶尔的现场访问是一个好方法，可以尝试实现这一点。而且规划如果做得对，我的意思是，这种事情不需要非常非常频繁地做。当然，计划的更新是需要的，但你知道，那种初始的东西不会发生得那么频繁。但我的意思是，你知道，有数字白板，你可以擦除和绘制
on and scribble for some reason they're just never quite as clean as uh whiteboard oh here's the bonus in real life one post-it notes oh yeah post-it notes plus whiteboard yep okay that's my two okay you can move on to the i guess more serious i mean i've used all of these they're okay you know jira asana open project these are all names that you'll hear i'm sure there are other ones too i can't remember but um you know all of them more or less do the same thing. I mean, if I had to recommend one, I would recommend Jira because it's free. You can have, I think, one or two projects for free. So if you're a student out there,
并在上面涂鸦，但出于某种原因，它们从来没有像白板那样干净。哦，这里有一个现实生活中的奖励：便利贴。哦，是的，便利贴加白板。是的，好的，这是我的两点建议。好的，你可以继续讲更严肃的内容。我的意思是，我用过所有这些，它们还可以。你知道，Jira、Asana、Open Project，这些都是你会听到的名字，我相信还有其他的，我不记得了。但你知道，它们或多或少都做同样的事情。我的意思是，如果我必须推荐一个，我会推荐Jira，因为它是免费的。我想你可以免费拥有一个或两个项目。所以如果你是一个学生，
I know the majority of our listeners are students, just use Jira. It's free. But the interface is a little clunky. Asana, I would say, is a slightly better interface. But is it worth the price? If you're a student, probably not. If you're a professional, then it matters less the cost of it.
我知道我们的大多数听众都是学生，就用Jira吧。它是免费的。但界面有点笨重。Asana，我会说界面稍微好一点。但它值得那个价格吗？如果你是学生，可能不值得。如果你是专业人士，那么成本就没那么重要了。
They're all great projects. They'll all help you. And they all have all sorts of integrations. So you can get a Slack message or an email whenever there's a new task and all that good stuff so we talked a little bit about the dealing with uncertainty oh uh there was one more tool i don't know anything about that open project do you know is that that's uh yeah open project is an open source kind of like jira equivalent and so if you you know there's times where where going open source just feels kind of cool or you might just be feeling like, I really don't want to depend
它们都是很棒的项目。它们都会对你有帮助。而且它们都有各种各样的集成。所以每当有新任务时，你都可以收到Slack消息或电子邮件，诸如此类。所以我们谈了一些关于处理不确定性的问题。哦，还有一个工具，我对那个Open Project一无所知，你知道吗？那是……是的，Open Project是一个开源的，类似于Jira的替代品。所以如果你知道，有时候选择开源感觉很酷，或者你可能只是觉得，我真的不想依赖
on any service or anything. I did run open projects sometime in the past and it was pretty good. It had a lot of the same features and your code, you can totally edit it and do whatever you want with it. If you are really into project planning to where you want with it if you are like really into project planning to where you want to sort of like hack on the project planner itself then you could use open project oh we also didn't cover but one you may hear a term is can ban and it's really sort of like in
任何服务或任何东西。我过去确实运行过Open Project，它相当不错。它有很多相同的功能，而且你的代码，你可以完全编辑它，随心所欲地处理它。如果你真的非常热衷于项目规划，以至于你想对项目规划工具本身进行修改，那么你可以使用Open Project。哦，我们还有一个没讲到，你可能会听到的一个术语是看板（Kanban），它实际上是
all of this stuff but but you know there are many many tools for doing for doing can ban boards but those are more or less having tasks on little boxes or Post-it notes and columns and sort of moving them for just trying to get into that low overhead, understanding that situations are dynamic and a sort of visual representation of it. But the final thing to just talk about is, you know, I guess to continue Jason's quote,
所有这些东西的一部分，但你知道，有很多工具可以用来做看板。但这些或多或少就是把任务放在小方框或便利贴上，放在列中，然后移动它们，只是为了尝试进入那种低开销的状态，理解情况是动态的，并对其进行视觉化呈现。但最后要谈的一点是，你知道，我想继续杰森的引用，
what happens when you get punched in the face, somebody gets sick, the goalposts get moved, whatever, you know, sort of happens, and your plan is no longer a sort of working. And we talked about making sure that you do have some padding, some buffering, specifically around things that are harder to schedule. Like Jason keeps talking about research and I think that's very difficult because it's sometimes very hard to put a specific time on when you're going to have that innovation or when it's going to occur. And so making sure you have buffering in the schedule
当你遭遇挫折、有人生病、目标被改变，无论发生什么，你知道，你的计划不再奏效时会发生什么。我们谈到了确保你确实有一些缓冲，特别是在那些更难安排的事情周围。就像杰森一直在谈论研究，我认为这非常困难，因为有时很难为创新何时发生或何时出现设定一个具体的时间。所以确保你在时间表中留有缓冲
can prevent it. But again, once you get punched in the face, it isn't really there, but making sure that everyone's very communicative and on the same space you know space and that you know being really honest with management that there needs to be slack in the uh in the schedule to say hey we're going to have issues we don't want to you know have everything booked you know end to end to end no no downtime no slack like that's just a way to have the you know expectations
可以防止这种情况。但同样，一旦你遭遇挫折，它就不再存在了，但要确保每个人都沟通顺畅，处于同一个空间，并且你知道，对管理层非常诚实，说明时间表中需要有余地，说嘿，我们会遇到问题，我们不想把所有事情都排得满满当当，没有停机时间，没有余地，那只是一个导致
get missed and then once they are missed, being honest, like for me, not everyone does it, but I try to be very clear when we're no longer tracking to schedule. A lot of people try to hide it and we'll make it up, we'll make it up. I'm a big believer of let's move the schedule and if we make it up, we'll move it back.
期望落空的方式。一旦期望落空，要诚实。对我来说，不是每个人都这样做，但我尽量在进度不再符合计划时非常明确。很多人试图掩盖它，说我们会补上的，我们会补上的。我坚信让我们调整进度，如果我们补上了，我们再把它调回来。
And that doesn't make me always popular with people, but stuff generally gets done. And as you get closer and closer, the certainty of that final date is is more nailed down and you're not always all situations aren't flexible like that but for me that's a huge thing is just saying listen that end date is going to move it will move less the closer we get but we should move it to be accurately reflecting of what's actually happening yeah i totally agree i think that we've covered this already,
这并不总是让我受欢迎，但事情通常能完成。随着你越来越接近最终日期，那个日期的确定性就越强。并不是所有情况都像那样灵活，但对我来说，这是一个巨大的事情，就是说，听着，那个结束日期会变动，越接近日期变动越小，但我们应该调整它以准确反映实际发生的情况。是的，我完全同意，我想我们已经涵盖了这一点，
but there's a short-term gain. I won't lie. I think there's literally, there is a short-term gain in fudging the numbers, making your plan in hindsight look incredibly prophetic and trying to sell some Cinderella story
但短期内是有收益的。我不会撒谎。我认为确实存在，在事后伪造数据，让你的计划看起来非常有预见性，并试图兜售某种灰姑娘故事，确实有短期收益。
about your team. You could probably do that especially if like your manager is also pretty junior like you could get away with that um but it will fall apart it is not a long-term strategy that is going to work um eventually the what is it the chickens will come home to roost uh after you get punched in the face and all the other analogies. But, you know, just being upfront and you could end up at an impasse where, you know, you feel like this set of goals is nominal, is expected. And your team disagrees or maybe a single person on your team says, you know, this is way more than I can accomplish. And those are very difficult conversations, which makes the project planning even more important.
关于你的团队。你可能可以做到这一点，特别是如果你的经理也很资深，你可以蒙混过关。但这会分崩离析，这不是一个长期有效的策略。最终，怎么说呢，因果报应终会到来，在你遭遇挫折和所有其他类比之后。但是，你知道，只要坦诚相待，你可能会陷入僵局，你知道，你觉得这套目标是名义上的，是预期的。而你的团队不同意，或者也许你团队中的一个人说，你知道，这远超我能完成的范围。这些是非常困难的对话，这使得项目规划变得更加重要。
So that at the end, you know, and this is not something that people like to talk about, but, you know, if you do have a person who's just not performing and you have to have some really hard conversations, you can say, look, like, here's the plan we set out. There was disagreement about the plan, but, you know, the rest of the team, you know, feels like this was a very reasonable plan that somebody could do in a reasonable amount of time. And that person didn't do it. And so we have to, you know,
所以最后，你知道，这不是人们喜欢谈论的事情，但你知道，如果你确实有一个表现不佳的人，你必须进行一些非常艰难的对话，你可以说，看，这是我们制定的计划。关于这个计划有分歧，但你知道，团队的其他成员觉得这是一个非常合理的计划，某人可以在合理的时间内完成。而那个人没有做到。所以我们必须，你知道，
have a performance discussion. So being able to do all of that planning up front and, and have those, you know, hard conversations up front is super important. And, and it will help give you sort of like a long-term sustainable team. All right. I think that about wraps it up. do you have any parting thoughts before uh
进行绩效讨论。所以能够提前做好所有规划，并进行那些艰难的对话是非常重要的。它将帮助你建立一个长期可持续的团队。好了，我想这就总结得差不多了。在我们在路上之前，你有什么临别赠言吗？
or we hit the road patrick uh just reiterating my disclaimer uh nothing we said no i'm just kidding uh yeah i mean everybody does it whether you want to or not informal formal like somewhere on the on the sort of gradient from nothing to overdoing it but you know project planning it happened i mean if you you know are gonna have a have a kid if you're going to get married if you're going to like projects and planning happens and um you know you can either sort of i don't sound bad blunderunder through it, or you can, you know, try to pick the best pieces that work for your situation and really try to have it be something that, you know, maybe it's not your expertise, but isn't a weakness. And so I think there's a lot of self-learning that can
帕特里克，只是重申我的免责声明，我们说的什么都不是，我开玩笑的。是的，我的意思是每个人都在做，无论你是否愿意。非正式的、正式的，在从“什么都不做”到“过度规划”的梯度上的某个位置。但你知道，项目规划确实发生了。我的意思是，如果你要生孩子，如果你要结婚，如果你要进行项目，规划就会发生。而且，你知道，你可以要么，我不想说得太难听，跌跌撞撞地走过去，或者你可以尝试挑选最适合你情况的部分，并真正尝试让它成为，你知道，也许它不是你的专长，但也不是弱点。所以我认为有很多自我学习可以
occur by planning things and then looking back and saying like, hey, they didn't go according to plan. That's okay. But like, you know, this was my plan. And sometimes a plan can be a little bit more audacious and, you know, be inspirational. But, you know, maybe you gotta be real that it's that. But, you know, sometimes you're right. Like I think, you know, in my personal life, I just try to say like, hey,
通过规划事情然后回顾并说，嘿，它们没有按计划进行。没关系。但你知道，这是我的计划。有时计划可以更大胆一点，你知道，具有启发性。但你知道，也许你得现实一点。但你知道，有时你是对的。就像我认为，在我的个人生活中，我只是试着说，嘿，
I'm gonna have a plan for the year and at the end of the year, look back and say, hey, did I hit or miss, right? And so not to get uh deeply philosophical i guess but you know i i think planning and goal setting and projects is something that's that that really goes across sort of all the things we do yeah and you know the other thing is there's a other side of this which is celebrate when your team does awesome you know i seen a lot of managers forget to do that
我今年要有一个计划，在年底回顾一下，说，嘿，我达到了还是错过了，对吧？所以不是要变得非常哲学，我想，但你知道，我认为规划、目标设定和项目是贯穿我们所做所有事情的事情。是的，你知道另一件事是，这还有另一面，那就是当你的团队表现出色时要庆祝。你知道，我见过很多经理忘记这样做，
um they're sort of like almost afraid of the first thing i said they're afraid of like people thinking oh we're sandbagging or whatever but like look back and say like wow have we set out to do five things we did six things they're all awesome and and we should throw a party and get sushi for everyone or something oh man i man, now I'm hungry. Oh, man, now I want sushi. All right, we will let everyone go. Super shout out. Thank you to our patrons.
他们有点害怕我说的第一件事，他们害怕人们认为“哦，我们在隐瞒实力”之类的。但回顾一下并说，哇，我们设定了要做五件事，我们做了六件事，它们都很棒，我们应该开个派对，给大家买寿司之类的。哦天哪，我现在饿了。哦天哪，我现在想吃寿司。好了，我们让大家走吧。超级感谢。感谢我们的赞助人。
We really appreciate your support. And now we should all go get some sushi. See you next time. Catch you later you and share alike in kind There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们非常感谢你们的支持。现在我们都应该去吃点寿司了。下次见。回头见。分享和同类相待。目前还没有关于这一集的评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。